phoenix vor ort liebe zuschauer bekommen
wir sind den ganzen tag heute über schon
in berlin denn deutschland hat einen
neuen bundeskanzler und eine neue
bundesregierung olaf scholz ist heute
gewählt worden 395 von 707 stimmen die
hatte bekommen im deutschen bundestag
olaf scholz ist der neunte bundeskanzler
in deutschland ja und nach willy brandt
helmut schmidt und gerhard schröder nun
der vierte für die spd ein durchaus
historischer tag in berlin
9 uhr im bundestag ein historischer tag
beginnt bei den vertretern der ampel
aufregung und vorfreude angela merkel
nimmt auf der tribüne platz sie ist
nicht mehr gewählt und darf deshalb
nicht mehr ins plenum ich begrüße auf
der ehrentribüne die geschäftsführende
bundeskanzlerin frau dr angela merkel
stehender applaus für merkel ganz
unberührt scheint sie das nicht zulassen
nach 16 jahren nach
5860 tagen scheidet sie aus dem amt
die eigentliche wahl des kanzlers dauert
jeder abgeordnete einzeln in eine
wahlkabine die wartezeit wird genutzt um
sich in neuen rollen kennen zu lernen
und für self es die hier eigentlich
verboten sind und
damit ich nicht
736 ordnungsrufe machen muss erlaube ich
gleich allen für diesen tag allen
abgeordneten
zu fotografieren aber bitte diskret
angespannt olaf scholz als das ergebnis
verlesen wird mit
395 stimmen wird er dann zum neuen
kanzler gewählt er bekommt nicht alle
stimmen der ampel vertreter und das
liegt nicht nur an den krankmeldungen
ich frage sie herr abgeordneter scholz
nehmen sie die wahl an
das war laut und vernehmlich applaus von
der ehefrau und vom vorgänger
glückwünsche und sträuße im plenum auch
von armin laschet eine deftige corona
faust zwischen den kontrahenten ums
kanzleramt
termin beim bundespräsidenten die
regierungsgewalt geht nun offiziell auf
scholz' über
im namen der bundesrepublik deutschland
wenn ich herrn olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler ist mein ganz herzlichen
glückwunsch
12 uhr zurück im bundestag die
bundestagspräsidentin nimmt wolf den
amtseid ab den leistet er ohne die
religiöse formel am ende ich schwöre
dass ich meine kraft dem wohle des
deutschen volkes widmen seinen nutzen
mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz und die gesetze des bundes
wahren und verteidigen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde und noch
einen termin im schloss bellevue das
erste ampel kabinett auf bundesebene
bekommt vom bundespräsidenten die
ernennungsurkunden
73 tage sind nach der wahl vergangen
eine neue regierung steht mit olaf
scholz wird nach 2005 zum ersten mal
wieder ein kanzler der spd das land
führen ja liebe zuschauer und wir warten
hier auf die direkte amtsübergabe die
heute noch im bundeskanzleramt erfolgt
angela merkel mit ihrem stab sie geht
raus und
olaf scholz mit seinem stab zieht ein
wie gesagt wir haben schon das
vorschaubild hier vorliegen bei uns aber
so lange wollen wir noch reden und zum
beispiel wartet jetzt in berlin mein
kollege gerd joachim von fallois neben
mir im studio steht professor tilman
mayer politologe von der uni bonn schön
dass sie uns behilflich sein wollen dass
wir den tag heute ein bisschen sortiert
bekommt ich geh zuerst mal nach berlin
derart joachim was würdest du denn sagen
nach 16 jahren jetzt eine neue
bundesregierung es wird ja heute immer
gesagt das ist ein historischer tag die
ampel so was hat deutschland noch nicht
gehabt wie hat das ganze denn auf sie
gewirkt ganz persönlich wenn sie heute
fazit ziehen
ja solche
vereinigungen von ministern und kanzlern
sind immer ein besonderer tag im
politischen berlin oder damals in bonn
und das sieht man auch teilweise an den
anziehsachen die der ein oder andere
sich angelegt hat da waren sehr hübsche
kleider zu sehen in ruhe stöckelschuhe
vor allen dingen interessanterweise
weniger bei vielen abgeordneten sondern
vor allen dingen bei den mitarbeitern
denn das darf man nicht vergessen bei so
einem regierungswechsel den wir jetzt
nach 16 jahren das erste mal wieder
haben werden sind ganz viele menschen
betroffen viele menschen in den
ministerien abteilungsleiter aufwärts
die jetzt heute ihren hut nehmen müssen
und andere die eben befördert werden und
mit den jeweiligen ministern in die
häuser einkehren und das ist dann schon
ein feierlicher moment für diejenigen
zumindest die dann ein neues amt
bekleiden werden und das hat man heute
doch auch allenthalben gespürt kommen
wir mal zurück bei uns ins studio herr
professor tilman mayer von der
universität in bonn also ich könnte mir
denken diese 100 tage schonfrist die man
anderen regierungen immer zugesteht die
wird angesichts der krisen die wir
gerade haben ich sagen oh corona krise
es ist mit der wirtschaft klimawandel
die wird die regierung wohl nicht haben
oder
ja ich weiss nicht genau also im bereich
pandemie natürlich nicht wird ja
sozusagen stündlich was erwartet
andererseits wenn wir an die russisch
ukrainische grenze denken ist natürlich
außenpolitisch und auch
sicherheitspolitisch eine alarmstimmung
da also es gibt durchaus dinge wo man
sagt da gibt es keine spielräume aber
insgesamt man hat es ja auch heute an
der stimmung gesehen ist man schon
geneigt auch diese regierung unter tage
zu geben und die opposition hält sich ja
auch in oppositionellen verhalten zurück
sodass also durchaus der spielräume sind
wie üblich sind die eben einfach zum
kommandeur des parlamentarismus gehören
mit dazu gehören ganz genau ich geh doch
mal rüber zu meinen kollegen nach berlin
der team von verlor also wir haben
natürlich heute den ganzen tag über
verfolgt was da im plenum passiert ist
was mir vereinen aufgefallen ist als im
bundestag dann die einzelnen minister
aufgerufen worden mein persönlicher
eindruck war der meiste applaus bei
annalena baerbock
ja das ist richtig und annalena baerbock
hat in der tat sehr sehr viel applaus
bekommen
aus den ampel fraktionen vor allen
dingen aber man muss auch sagen dass die
größte oppositionsfraktion die cdu/csu
und auch die linke der also diese beiden
oppositionsfraktionen heute in ihren
äußerungen sehr zurückhaltend waren fast
staatstragend und insofern war das eine
richtige beobachtung vielleicht darf ich
an der stelle noch erwähnen am
interessantesten an solchen tagen sind
immer die beobachtungen die außerhalb
der kameras stattfinden da haben wir
reporter dann glück vor ort können dass
ein bisschen beobachten ich sage nämlich
als die minister zurück kamen vom herrn
bundespräsidenten plötzlich einen neuen
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister nämlich
cem özdemir mit einem fahrrad helm auf
dem kopf und einer blauen regenjacke
quasi marschierte er in den bundestag
rhein hat das dann aber vor der tür dann
noch normal abgegeben er ist tatsächlich
mit dem fahrrad die anderthalb kilometer
vom bundestag zum schloss bellevue
geradelt das ist glaube ich ein novum
das habe ich auch noch nicht erlebt ja
ja das haben wir haben auch gewartet bis
die wagenkolonne kam und dann plötzlich
kam zum thema angelaufen hat das fahrrad
hingestellt das war schon sehr
interessant herr professor meyer wir
hatten gerade die neue bundes
aussenministerin annalena baerbock das
ist natürlich eine ganz hohe
verantwortung eine ganz hohe
herausforderung die auf diese junge frau
das erste mal das amt von einer frau
geführt hinzu kommt wir haben das gerade
gehört es gibt die krise in der ukraine
zwischen der usa und russland es wird
auch ein geschick ankommen um eine große
herausforderung
diplomatische vermittlung und annalena
baerbock hat ja in den letzten tagen
schon was richtung china gesagt also ich
denke mal das ist eine sehr komplizierte
aufgabe ja durchaus vulkanes dass da
irgendwie das hochkommen kann und voller
risiken und insofern wird man ihr nicht
wünschen wollen dass sie gleich ins
kalte wasser springt im sinne von
vermittlungs aufgaben gar das finde ich
wieder wer sie sicherlich überfordert
aber es muss ja erstmal einmal sozusagen
für anerkennung respekt ihr gegenüber
sorgen die der international zum
ausdruck kommt ihre stellungnahme
gegenüber china war ja schon mal ein
bisschen riskant und kam sofort eine
entsprechende meldung zurück als china
andererseits der der chinesische
präsident hat ja ganz auffallend schnell
den bundeskanzler gratuliert so dass
also auf dieser schiene die ja auch eine
auswärtige angelegenheit sozusagen
verkörpert ist das kanzleramt da
funktionieren
die deutsch chinesischen beziehungen
immer noch wie gehabt wegen der großen
koalition insofern ist auch die
schwierigkeit für vorwerk sich hier in
einer rolle zu finden dass sie da nicht
zu kurz kommt in gewisser weise das muss
sich alles einspielen aber muss man
immer sofort passieren müssen insofern
ist es schon der herausforderung und
wenn ich so sagen darf da genügt es
nicht wenn man vom völkerrecht herkommt
sondern man braucht dann auch eine
gewisse erfahrung und gute ratschläge
die ihnen natürlich in dem amt
sicherlich freuen sind der ist ja
sicherlich ein exzellenter start
dahinter deutlichkeit sagen ja liebe
zuschauer ich höre gerade aus der regie
wir gucken jetzt mal kurz ins
bundeskanzleramt und gerd vielleicht
können sie uns mal sagen sie kennen sich
ja bestens aus in den örtlichkeiten ich
habe gehört angela merkel soll auch
schon da sein wo ist dass da jetzt
gerade auf welcher ebene findet das
statt
tja der ausschnitt ist schwer zu
erkennen das ist glaube ich im ersten
stock da wo auch die presse konferenzen
normalerweise stattfinden vor einer
blauen wand weiter rechts von diesem
bildausschnitt da hängen die porträts
der bundeskanzler auch das eine große
frage hier im politischen berlin wer
wird angela merkel malen sie kommt ja
dann in diese galerie wie bundeskanzler
die scheidenden bundeskanzler können
sich den künstler selber aussuchen so
ist das tradition und wir sehen hier
glaube ich auch schon gerne aus helge
braun die haben dann auch noch kurz
gesprochen habe das ist auch eine ganz
interessante geschichte auch helge braun
erzählte wie der ein oder andere
scheiben der unions minister das ist
schon eine komische situation ist für
minister die ausscheiden denn sie haben
sind ja vor einigen tagen beim
bundespräsidenten gewesen haben ihre
entlassungsurkunden bekommen und seitdem
haben sie von keiner offiziellen stelle
mehr irgendetwas gehört es ist dann wohl
so es gibt traditionen ja aber man
telefoniert sich dann zusammen mit dem
stab zum beispiel des neuen amtsinhabers
und legt dann selber fest wann machen
wir was also es gibt jetzt nicht
irgendwie ein eine normierung für die
minister an dem tag muss um so und
soviel uhr das haus verlassen haben das
wird individuell einzeln geregelt und wo
wir jetzt hier gerade bei der übergabe
des bundeskanzleramtes sind fällt mir
ein ich kann mich sehr gut erinnern an
einen wechsel 994
1998 beton von helmut kohl auf gerhard
schröder auch da ja ein neuer
bundeskanzler und das ist schon ein
unterschied also wenn angela merkel ihre
wahl wieder gewonnen hätte oder hat denn
das ist natürlich für viele die jetzt
auch darum stehen viele spitzenbeamten
im kanzleramt aber auch für diejenigen
die doch keinen spitzen job hat
natürlich eine zäsur
abteilungsleiter aufwärts können diese
leute zum beispiel eine frühzeitige
pension geschickt werden weil sie
vermutlich auch eher ein anderes
parteibuch haben wenn sie denn eins
haben und dann ziehen da ganz neue leute
an eine ausnahme gibt es das ist das
auswärtige amt über das wir eben schon
gesprochen haben die diplomaten das ist
ein geschlossener kreis das ist wie ein
chor das ist übrigens auch für die neuen
minister nicht so einfach sie können
fast keine eigenen mitarbeiter
mitbringen im gegensatz zu den
amtskollegen die anderen bringen ihre
eigenen mitarbeiter mit im auswärtigen
amt geht das so einfach nicht und das
wird sicherlich für annalena baerbock
eine herausforderung auf der anderen
seite auch eine stütze von erfahrenen
beamten geleitet werden zu können ja ich
sehe hier gerade angela merkel wird
jetzt vor mit olaf scholz da sind die
beiden monika grütters claudia roth
haben wir gesehen zum beispiel den neuen
kanzleramtsminister und ich würde sagen
wir hören da jetzt einfach mal rein mal
sehen wie lange das jetzt noch dauert
teilte browne er hat ja noch viel vor
kandidiert für den cdu-vorsitz da sollst
das ergebnis der mitgliederentscheidung
am 17 dezember führen aber jetzt ist die
stunde der amtsübergabe der neue
hausherr olaf scholz
63 jahre jung neunter bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland
genau daneben sehen wir wolfgang schmidt
seinen vertrauten jetzt kanzleramtschef
also die übergabe mit helge braun und
jetzt angela merkel ja meine damen und
herren aber vor allen dingen lieber herr
bundeskanzler lieber olaf scholz und
diejenigen die dazugehören herr schmidt
der zukünftige chef des bundes kann der
schon der chef des bundeskanzleramtes
ist der
noch nicht ernannte glaube ich
regierungssprecher
die staatsminister hier im kanzleramt
ich möchte ganz herzlich begrüßen und
das wo ich auch im namen all derer die
vorher diese funktion eingenommen hatten
ich konnte heute weiß ich nicht mehr
mitglied des deutschen bundestages bin
auch stolz noch nicht persönlich
gratulieren und möchte dass deshalb auf
diesem wege nachholen herzlichen
glückwunsch sehr geehrter bundeskanzler
heber olaf scholz ich weiß aus eigenem
erleben dass es ein bewegender moment
ist in dieses amt gewählt zu werden wie
er an vielleicht dass es eine spannende
erfüllende aufgabe ist auch eine
fordernde aufgabe aber wenn man sie mit
freude an geht dann ist es vielleicht
auch eine der schönsten aufgaben die es
gibt für dieses land verantwortung zu
tragen ich wünsche ihnen von herzen
alles gute bei dieser arbeit und immer
eine glückliche hand für unser land und
diese wünsche erstrecken sich auch auf
das ganze team
cola bedingt sind wir heute in einem
sehr kleinen kreis hier versammelt als
ich damals von gerd schröder diese
aufgabe übernommen habe stand die
gesamte süd treppe voller
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die uns
jetzt zum teil auch zu hören und ich
darf ihnen sagen sie werden hier eine
mannschaft vorfinden die voller
leidenschaft voller engagement arbeitet
tag und wenn es sein muss auch nachts
die immer einsatzbereit ist motiviertes
gute ideen hat fachkundig ist und das
gilt für alle das gilt vom innen schutz
bis zu allen referenten gruppenleitern
und abteilungsleitern das gilt von denen
die in der küche arbeiten bis zur
registratur der poststelle und in vielen
vielen aufgaben die hier ineinander
greifen müssen der sich einmal ins
kanzleramt
bewegt auch als mitarbeiter oder
mitarbeiterin der weiß was politik
bedeutet nämlich dass man morgens wenn
man aufsteht und hier zum dienst geht
nicht weiß was bis zum abend passiert
ist das ist immer dazu kommen kann dass
man auch auf ganz neue herausforderungen
acht muss ich weiß dass sie mit großer
motivation jetzt an die arbeit gehen und
deshalb
nehmen sie dieses haus in besitz und
arbeiten sie mit ihm zum besten unseres
landes das ist mein wunsch und ich
wünsche ihnen dabei alles gute
[Applaus]
ja sind wir live dabei im berliner
kanzleramt das ist die amtsübergabe die
bisherige hausherrin angela merkel tritt
von der bühne ab und ihr folgt der neue
bundesanwalt die bundeskanzlerin ich
möchte mich sehr für ihre arbeit in den
letzten 16 jahren bedanken ich glaube
dass man hier sehr genau und sehr
präzise sagen kann das war eine große
zeit in der sie kanzlerin dieses landes
waren und sie haben auch großartiges
bewegt wir haben viele viele
herausforderung zu bewältigen gehabt
aber es waren immer wieder auch große
krisen die auf uns zugekommen sind
manche haben wir gemeinsam
durchgestanden in unterschiedlichen
funktionen aber auch ich als mitglied
des von ihnen geführten kabinetts ich
erinnere nur an die finanzkrise
2008/2009 hier immer an die großen
herausforderungen die mit der flucht
migration 215 folgende verbunden waren
und natürlich jetzt wieder die große
ökonomische soziale
herausforderung die mit der krone
pandemie verbunden ist das hat
zusammengeschweißt und das waren nicht
nur diese ereignisse und zwischen uns
hat immer eine sehr vertrauensvolle art
der zusammenarbeit existiert das glaube
ich ist doch gut weil es zeigt dass wir
eine starke leistungsfähige demokratie
sind in der es einen großen konsens gibt
zwischen den verantwortlichen
demokratinnen und demokraten und es wird
auch in zukunft weiter umso stärker
ausmachen trotzdem sie haben dieses land
geprägt und auch diese regierung und
auch dieses haus und deshalb glaube ich
sagen zu können ist es schon irgendwie
was besonderes und ich will gerne
anknüpfen an die wie soll man das sagen
nordostdeutsche mentalität die da bisher
geherrscht hat so viel wird sich da
nicht ändern
ich glaube dass wir alle hier
zurückgreifen können wie sie das schon
gesagt haben auf ganz großartige arbeit
die viele geleistet haben großartige
arbeit von den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern hier im haus und das ist
mir auch bisher schon sehr klar geworden
in den verantwortlichkeiten die ich
bisher hatte und deshalb freue ich mich
auf die enge zusammenhang danke sagen
möchte ich nicht nur ihnen sondern auch
all den anderen die hier an
verantwortlicher stelle
gesessen haben und gewirkt haben und die
mit ihnen hier versammelt sind auch da
ist viel an kooperationen und
zusammenarbeit in den letzten jahren
gewesen und daran anzuknüpfen und darauf
aufzubauen das wird mir jedenfalls eine
große ehre sein ich finde es ist etwas
ganz besonderes bundeskanzler dieser
republik zu sein es ist eine große
herausforderung
ich bin sehr dankbar dass ich nun von
den bürgerinnen und bürgern dieses
landes und vom deutschen bundestag den
auftrag gekriegt habe das zu machen dass
wir so lange so viele gemeinsame
erfahrung sammeln könnten das wird mir
dabei helfen schönen dank mal nochmal
für ihre arbeit
ja und noch mal an die mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiter denen heute nicht versammelt
sein können aber die uns zuhören den
streams und den verschiedenen büros
gerichtet danke für das was sie bisher
geleistet haben danke für das was sie
leisten werden ich baue darauf und
setzte darauf und wir wissen dass der
übergang den wir jetzt hier miteinander
vollziehen einer ist mitten in einer
großen nicht abgeschlossenen krise das
setzt kontinuität und gemeinschaft
voraus und ich gehe davon aus dass uns
das auch gelingt vermerken nicht wissen
dass wir die krone pandemie nur
bekämpfen können in dem sich viele
impfen und lassen und viele
auffrischungsimpfungen holen indem wir
vorsichtig sind das gehört dazu und
deshalb ist es auch richtig dass unsere
zusammenkunft hier so etwas
begrenzt ist was die zahl der real
anwesenden betrifft das wir masken
tragen wenn wir am platz sitzen es ist
die grundlage dafür dass das gut
gelingen kann ich jedenfalls bin sehr
dankbar für das was wir bisher gemacht
haben ich freue mich auf die neue
aufgabe ich freue mich auf alle die hier
arbeiten und es war ein guter aufbruch
werden für unser land ich will
jedenfalls alles dafür tun schönen dank
ja soweit aus dem bundeskanzleramt die
übergabe des staffelstabes von bisher
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel an den
neuen an den neunten bundeskanzlerin
bundespräsident olaf scholz und jetzt
gucken wir mal weiter frau
bundeskanzlerin
ich spreche heute vertretend halt für
die belegschaft die ja leider nur am
bildschirm zu schauen kann wir haben
halt besondere zeiten aber man war es in
den letzten 16 jahren schon mal anders
in
den letzten 16 jahren haben sie nicht
nur dieses haus geprägt sondern das
ganze land europa und die welt wir als
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter hätten
uns durchaus mal ein paar ruhige jahre
gewünscht vielleicht auch mal ein
altmodisches sommerloch aber man kann ja
nun mal nicht alles haben ihre abendzeit
bundeskanzler scholz hat es gerade
angesprochen aber von vielen krisen
geprägt wir hatten die finanzkrise wir
hatten die flüchtlinge wir hatten
terrorismus afghanistan corona in all
diesen jahren in all diesen besonderen
situationen waren sie trotzdem stehe
jetzt unprätentiös unaufgeregt und ruhig
sie waren stets nager hatten ein nettes
wort und einen gruß auch für die kleinen
lichter und das kann ich aus eigener
erfahrung beurteilen sie haben jeden auf
augenhöhe war bild dass es nicht
selbstverständlich
wir danken ihnen und dem kanzleramtschef
minister brauchen für das
entgegengebrachte vertrauen und die gute
zusammenarbeit in den vergangenen jahren
und wünschen ihnen für ihren weiteren
lebensweg alles gute
sie sagten ja mal sie wollen jetzt ein
wenig schlafen und dann mal sehen wie es
weitergeht wir hoffen dass sie auch in
zukunft etwas zeit für das wandern
wieder finden und haben dann natürlich
daran gedacht und möchten ihn im
anschluss bei einer kleinigkeit dazu mit
auf den weg geben und auch für sie
professor braun auch wenn sie im
anschluss sozusagen wieder im bundestag
etwas aktiver sind als
als vielleicht erhofft wie auch immer
auch ihnen unsere hoffnung dass sie
vielleicht etwas mehr zeit für ihre
hobbys in zukunft haben auch wenn sie
haben eine kleinigkeit vorbereitet gar
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler unseren
ganz herzlichen glückwunsch im namen
aller kolleginnen und kollegen dieses
hauses zur wahl zum neuen bundeskanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland
sie übernehmen mit dem heutigen tage ein
besonderes haus
wie es so schön heißt niemand ist
zufällig ins kanzleramt gekommen
das ist schon eine ausgewählte und
besondere mannschaft die sich hier
erwartet keiner partei verpflichtet
sondern dem land gut vernetzt und
sachkundig um ihnen die bestmögliche
information und beratung zu liefern
ihnen herr bundeskanzler und ihnen herr
minister schmit er zukünftig unserer
dienststellenleiter wir wünschen ihnen
alles erdenklich gute für die
bevorstehenden aufgaben
sie können sich sicher sein dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen des
bundeskanzleramt des ihres amtes
stets treu und loyal mit besten kräften
und gewissen hin zur seite stehen
herzlich willkommen noch mal und wir
freuen uns auf die zusammenarbeit danke
ja so weiß jetzt aus berlin das war noch
mal der sprecher des personalrates im
kanzleramt er hat noch mal herzlich
willkommen gesagt und auf wiedersehen
und jetzt kriegt angela merkel auch von
ihm noch einen wunderschönen
blumenstrauß da hat sie heute schon ganz
viele bekommen
ja
ja wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich in
berlin frage ich mal unseren
hauptstadtkorrespondenten werk joachim
von fallois also die einen gehen die
anderen kommen also im prinzip sind die
ein jetzt im amt also man muss dann
nicht mehr sagen die ehemalige die
geschäftsführende bundeskanzlerin
sondern die neuen posten ab jetzt gilt
es die amtsübergabe vollziehen sich ja
noch an diesen nachmittag in den
einzelnen ressorts
es ist verfassungsrechtlich so dass mit
dem erhalt der ernennungsurkunde durch
den bundespräsidenten wird der
bundeskanzler zum bundeskanzler ist es
nicht der eid im parlament der hätte
auch später geleistet werden können
sondern es ist diese urkunde und die
endung durch den herrn bundespräsidenten
das gilt auch für die minister insofern
sind sie schon ins im amt wenn sie jetzt
hier die amtsübergabe machen und angela
merkel ist seit dem heutigen tage die
ehemalige bundeskanzlerin und olaf
scholz ab dieser sekunde daneben auch
der hausherr im kanzleramt aber ich habe
es vorhin schon mal angedeutet hinter
diesen schönen bildern verbirgt sich ja
viel viel mehr
abteilungsleiter eben ja ist man ein
politischer beamter und viele von denen
auch im kanzleramt die jetzt in dieser
funktion sind da gibt es nicht so
furchtbar viele die werden sicherlich in
einstweiligen ruhestand geschickt werden
denn die werden dann durch getreue des
bundeskanzlers besitzt ähnlich wird das
in den ministerien seien das ist so
üblich wie gesagt im auswärtigen amt
gilt da eine etwas andere regelung ja
und angela merkel sehen jetzt hier acht
in der tat einige der blumensträuße die
sie bekommen hat zusammen und geht jetzt
mit dem bundeskanzler wahrscheinlich vor
die tür und dann ist die abfahrt und bei
diesen bildern bin ich doch noch einmal
erinnert an den anfang dieses jahres
auch noch einmal richtung amerika gucken
so kann man es eben auch machen und
angela merkel hat es ja vorbildlich
gemacht sie ist die erste deutsche
bundeskanzlerin die von aus eigenen
stücken gegangen ist nicht abgewählt
wurde und nicht weg geputzt oder
sonstwas wurde sondern sie hat sich
entschieden nicht noch einmal anzutreten
und sie hat seit einigen wochen olaf
scholz der ja zugegebenermaßen
vizekanzler war da war das etwas
einfacher bei vielen veranstaltungen
mitgenommen eingeführt in dieses neue
amt was er jetzt begleitet und hat ihn
vorgestellt das war bei manchen gar
nicht mehr nötig auch bei manchen großen
olaf scholz ist gut vernetzt in der welt
aber es ist doch schon angenehm wenn
angela merkel einem herrn beiden nochmal
persönlich vorstellt oder ein putin dass
dies sind ist dann schon ganz angenehm
auch für den neuen bundeskanzler das
kann ich mir vorstellen herr professor
tilman mayer von der uni bonn kommt mama
zurück ins studio es sind viele schöne
nette worte gesagt worden am ende
natürlich die verabschiedung aber wir
dürfen uns da natürlich nicht zu machen
der bundespräsident hatte hatte auch
gesagt das ist eine zeit des wandels
wird der wir stehen die leute erhoffen
sich erwarten führung in der krise was
zeichen des aufbruchs was sind die
größten unterschiede ich meine es ist ja
doch eine historische zäsur nach zehn
jahren nach 16 jahren bundeskanzler
schafft von angela merkel jetzt mit der
ampel ja das ist ein politikwechsel der
eben lange nicht erfolgte es gab ja
wirklich einen immensen aufmarsch an
versuchen sie aus dem amt zu bringen und
das gelang nicht und erneut ist es jetzt
erst genauer gelungen nachdem sie selber
gesagt hat sie würde nicht mehr antreten
natürlich ist es wie bei einem haus
umzug oder wohnungs neubezug dann will
man natürlich entsprechend neu
tapezieren usw es gibt natürlich anlass
das ein oder andere anders zu machen
zumal muss man sagen diese ablösung
durch den vizekanzler natürlich ideal
ist insofern als sich ja eigentlich
bestens auskennt in dem bisherigen
maschinenraum und insofern auch wüsste
wo man eigentlich neues ansetzen muss
und ich glaube in dieser richtung will
er unterwegs sein der führung bestellt
bekommt führung heißt es ja bei ihm wir
haben das in hamburg gesehen dass er
dazu
die lage ist und auch entsprechende
zustimmung dann daraus erwächst er hat
noch nicht alle hürden genommen auch
persönliche art comic skandal ist immer
noch schwebt ein bisschen schwelt auch
im hintergrund
andererseits hat man den eindruck dass
hier jemand sehr solides ins haus kommt
der das geschäft versteht und
beherrschen kann die aussenpolitische er
muss man nochmal sehen inwiefern das
gelingt auf augenhöhe mit putin shipping
und so weiter zu sein das kann man sich
im moment noch nicht so ganz vorstellen
aber ist natürlich jetzt dann fällig und
ob dann die 100 tage die sie vorhin
ansparen für mich sind das wird man
sehen vielleicht ist eben auch schon am
wochenende eine andere sache denn haben
die ersten reisen führen ja schon nach
paris nach brüssel ja liebe zuschauer
interessant waren natürlich auch man
fragt sich olaf scholz was ist das für
ein mensch seine ehefrau britta ernst
kultusministerin in brandenburg sie hat
das ganze heute mit verfolgt sie sass
auf der tribüne sie hat kein leichtes
amt in der korona pandemie ist auch noch
chefin der kultusministerkonferenz es
waren die eltern von olaf scholz dabei
einer seiner brüder und auch seine
schwiegereltern haben das im bundestag
alles live mitverfolgt und sein vater 86
jahre der hat heute der deutschen presse
agentur gesagt mensch wenn er sich das
hätte träumen lassen vor 63 jahren als
sein sohn geboren wurde da hat darauf
geachtet dass er nicht aus dem
kinderwagen feld und jetzt sitzt er mit
den großen führer dieser welt am tisch
ja olaf scholz wir haben uns mal gefragt
was ist das für mensch und wir haben für
sie ein porträt vorbereitet
scholz als juso in den 80ern das linke
gewissen von damals habe er sich
erhalten sagte er auch wenn er vielen in
der eigenen partei inzwischen als zu
pragmatisch gilt als vizekanzler und
finanzminister will er politik für die
mitte der gesellschaft machen selbst
wenn das viel kostet wie handelnder
pragmatisch und sachgerecht und wir
verehren keinen fetisch am anfang der
legislaturperiode konnte scholz viel
geld ausgeben ohne neue schulden machen
zu müssen die steuereinnahmen sprudeln
die schwarz-rote koalition kann
milliarden in die sozialpolitik
investieren
die kassenlage ändert sich erst mit der
korona krise gemeinsam mit der kanzlerin
bleibt scholz trotzdem seiner politik
treu im zweifelsfall lieber großzügig zu
finanzieren als das land kaputt zu
sparen das was wir machen ist erstmal
ich
weiß nicht ob man das hier sagen haben
das ist die besucher mit der wir gibt
das notwendige jetzt tun und was wir
denn noch an kleinwaffen brauchen das
gucken wir später als seine größte
niederlage bezeichnete der olaf scholz
wir gehen jetzt rüber nach berlin es
geht schlag auf schlag mit den
amtsübergabe der bisherige
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
übergibt an robert habeck
meine sehr geehrte frau grünewald vom
personalrat mit ihren begleiterinnen und
begleiter frau robert als
gleichstellungsbeauftragte der geehrte
parlamentarische staatssekretäre der
alten wie die neuen ausziehen aus dem
haus werden dieser winkelmeier becker
thomas bareiß und marco wanderwitz neu
einziehen werden franziska brantner
michael kellner und oliver krischer sehr
geehrte beamtete staatssekretäre meiner
eigenen rechners baum claudia dörr fonds
und andreas feicht dessen arbeitsvertrag
bereits in der letzten woche zum ende
kam und die neuen herr giegold herr
philip und vor allen dingen lieber anja
hajduk wir kennen uns seit längerer zeit
und schätzen uns zumindest kann ich das
aus unserer zusammenarbeit so sagen ich
freue mich dass ihr alle gekommen sind
zu dieser etwas ungewöhnlichen
amtseinführung ich hab meine luft und
raumfahrt beauftragt um als der zum bag
den ich erwähnen möchte und ich freue
mich dass sie alle gekommen sind zu
dieser etwas ungewöhnlichen
amtseinführung corona geschuldet
normalerweise wäre dieser ludwig erhard
saal die aula des hauses vollgefüllt
randvoll gefüllt mit interessierten
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern die
alle die neue führung kennenlernen
möchten unterhalten führung gerne noch
einmal ein adieu zu rufen möchten das
war heute nicht möglich ist eine sehr
begrenzte zahl von teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer aber es ist wichtig dass wir
in der demokratie auch die chance nutzen
die demokratische die friedliche auch
die einvernehmliche übergabe so zu
demonstrieren dass deutlich wird wir
haben die zeiten als sich demokraten
gegenseitig bekämpft haben in weimar und
die zeiten als es heftige
auseinandersetzungen gab zum ende der
ära adenauer
erhard kiesinger und zu beginn der ära
brandt und schmidt diese zeiten haben
wir hinter uns gelassen wir sind heute
im stande und fähig den übergang von
politischer verantwortung von
demokratischer macht demokratisch zu
organisieren und das ist ein wert an
sich natürlich wohnt jedem neuen anfang
ein zauber inne aber eben auch der keim
des abschieds demokratie ist immer
verantwortung auf zeit und das ist ein
wichtiges prinzip dass es bereits bei
den alten griechen bei den alten römern
gab aus gutem grund und deshalb wissen
wir alle wenn wir so ein haus betreten
dass wir es auch wieder verlassen werden
und dennoch ist es ein besonderer moment
lieber robert habeck und ich bin sicher
sie haben das auch so erkunden ich habe
es empfunden in besonderer weise als ich
seinerzeit das bundesumweltministerium
als minister zum ersten mal betreten
habe weil man die verantwortung hat für
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
wenn man die verantwortung trägt für die
politik des hauses aber auch für die
politik des landes insgesamt
es muss zusammengedacht werden was
eigentlich nicht zusammengehören möchte
man glaubt dass die inhalte
gegensätzlichen und sie werden diese
aufgabe sich stellen müssen weil eine
kluge entscheidung der koalition darin
besteht dass man die große
transformation
nämlich das
zusammenwachsen von
ökologie und ökonomie in einem haus
verankert hat was nicht alle probleme
löst aber sicherlich synergie effekte
ermöglicht und manche ressort abstimmung
etwas leichter macht weil sie gar nicht
stattfinden muss harry den ich sehe als
ehemaliger abteilungsleiter und andere
haben das in der vergangenheit leidvoll
erfahren ich würde heute keine großen
reden halten ich möchte mich gerne
gedanken bei meinen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter das sage ich ganz besonders
und vorne weg weil jörg semmler wird
sich daran erinnern im kanzleramt als
wir damals die übergabe gemacht haben
vor vier jahren war mir das
unverzeihlicher weise entfallen und
deshalb möchte ich mich bei dem eigenen
team als erstes bedanken ich möchte
namentlich herausheben und nennen monika
knauer dem eine sekretärin war als
erster parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
war die mich begleitet hat ins
umweltministerium ins bundeskanzleramt
ins bundeswirtschaftsministerium
und ohne deren mithilfe und ohne deren
umsicht ist mir sicherlich viel schwerer
gefallen wäre die belastungen des amtes
zu verkraften ich möchte mich bedanken
bei meinen fahrern die meine monologe
ausgehalten haben während der vielen
vielen fahrten von a nach b und immer so
taten als seien sie interessiert an dem
was der minister zu erzählen hatte ich
möchte mich bedanken bei meiner die it
gehört nicht dem minister sie gehört im
ganzen haus und die it war vor eine
unglaubliche herausforderung gestellt in
der korona pandemie wie wir alle weil
wir hunderte vielleicht sogar tausende
von telefonkonferenzen videokonferenzen
in kürzester zeit
organisieren mussten ich kann sagen ich
habe sicherlich mehr als 100 davon
persönlich erlebt und mitgemacht keine
einzige ist zusammengebrochen ist
abgestürzt ich hatte immer
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die
sich engagiert haben das gilt für das
protokoll das gilt für diejenigen einem
engen umfeld die mir immer den
leitungsbereich gefolgt sind für jörg
semmler für dominik geister
wir wollen schreiber für tanja alemany
feuerwehrmann und länger meine reise
marshall es gilt aber auch für die
partner es gilt für die
sicherheitsangestellten für die boten
für das protokoll aber natürlich dann
auch für die fachabteilungen das haus
hat eine wechselvolle geschichte erlebt
aber es ist ein klassisches ressort und
es ist ein respektiertes ressort ludwig
erhard der so oft und so falsch zitiert
wird hat diesem haus einen legendären
ruf verschafft aber in dem gedränge des
alltags und der täglichen entscheidungen
sind oftmals andere aspekte auch
wichtiger gewesen und vor diesem
hintergrund ist es gelungen dank der
arbeit der fachabteilungen dass wir uns
respekt zurück erkämpft haben das gilt
ganz besonders für krone ich habe in
meinem abschiedsbrief heute morgen
verschickt wurde per e-mail um holz zu
sparen und bäume zu schonen lieber
robert habeck wir gehen mit der neuen
zeit habe ich darauf hingewiesen dass
das das große überwölbende thema war das
natürlich die abteilung 7
die hilfsprogramme verwaltet hat
zusammen mit der abteilung 1 beschäftigt
hat aber auch ganz viele andere mehr wir
haben hier wie in allen häusern auch
krankheitsfälle gehabt von corona von
familienoberhäupter von frauen und
männern von mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern
wir haben 80 prozent der belegschaft in
home office lösungen unterbringen können
um die sozialen kontakte zu reduzieren
und wir haben mitgeholfen das 400
milliarden euro
mobilisiert wurden für die
unterschiedlichen hilfsleistungen die
allermeisten davon unter der
verantwortung eines staatssekretärs
ulrich nußbaum und der abteilung 7 und
der abteilung 1 von den soforthilfen
über die verschiedenen
überbrückungshilfen 123 und demnächst
vier über den wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds mit
dramatischen aktionen die auch
öffentlich widerhall gefunden haben wie
etwa die lufthansa rettung und vieles
andere mehr es ist gelungen die substanz
der volkswirtschaft zu erhalten und sie
bauen auf einem bewusstsein der
gegenseitigen zusammenarbeit wie ist das
so
das darf ich sagen noch nicht gegeben
hat ja und dann hat es viele
battlegrounds gegeben viele
auseinandersetzungen wo es wichtig war
dass man auch einmal einen aufschlag
macht und wir lieber robert habeck als
wir uns getroffen haben zum allerersten
mal in der friedrich krupp einer
seehundstation wo ein punkt vorgesehen
war
die fütterung der seehunde mit heringen
und natürlich das nordlicht robert
habeck dafür geübt da war als ich und
den ganzen einmal verfüttern wollte
bevor ich überhaupt zum zuge kam und da
habe ich festgestellt dass wir beide ein
talent haben nicht nur zum seehund
füttern sondern eben auch dazu die dinge
zu erläutern und sie so zu positionieren
dass sie öffentlich bemerkt und
diskutiert werden können wir haben der
industrie strategie entwickelt und ja
der koalitionsvertrag hat recht dass
dort das thema der ökologischen
transformation
nicht hinreichend reflektiert ist warum
weil wir damals eben als bundesregierung
noch nicht sprechen ich waren zu diesem
thema und es war eines der
umstrittensten in den eigenen reihen in
meiner partei aber nicht nur in meiner
partei sondern auch in der koalition
insgesamt wir haben die mittelstands
strategie verabschiedet vieles davon
umgesetzt für den mittelstand ist vor
allen dingen wichtig rahmenbedingungen
für investitionen bezahlbare
energiepreise bezahlbare sozialabgaben
wir haben die
batteriezelle produktion nach
deutschland zurückgeholt wir haben die
ship industrie nicht nur hier erhalten
wir werden es ermöglichen oder sie
werden es ermöglichen wir haben versucht
noch vorarbeiten zu machen wir haben den
finanzminister
gedrückt bis er auch vor der wahl vor
dem wahlkampf noch mal eine milliarde
zusätzlich draufgelegt hat sie werden
noch vier oder fünf brauchen für die
produktion in mikrochips und die
investitionen die viele unternehmen hier
tun wollen es ist für die industrielle
basis wichtige und egal ob die
mikrochips in asien oder in europa
produziert werden sie müssen nachhaltig
produziert werden hier wie dort und wenn
sie nachhaltig produziert werden da gibt
es keinen grund warum sie nicht auch bei
uns produziert werden müssen das thema
garics eine souveräne dateninfrastruktur
in der daten ökonomie die europäische
präsidentschaft in der eu mit fünf rats
formationen die förderung der start-ups
durch den zukunftsfonds all das sind
themen ich will sie nicht im einzelnen
aufzählen die uns in atem gehalten haben
und eines will ich besonders erwähnt es
sind sehr geehrte robert ist die
freistellung ich hatte als
kanzleramtsminister im nebenjob war ich
als cdu-mitglied und bin es auch
natürlich jahr über geblieben aber ich
hatte damals als cdu-mitglied die
aufgabe ein regierungsprogramm zu
entwerfen unter der ägide von der angela
merkel und horst seehofer und was habe
ich rein geschrieben dass wir die
gleichstellung in führungspositionen bis
zur mitte des jahrzehnts vollenden
wollen wir haben angefangen es ist uns
nicht getraut wurden von allen es war
auch schwer aber wir haben unser ziel
von 40 prozent frauen in
führungspositionen sogar übertroffen wir
sind bei 43 sie müssen jetzt noch sieben
prozent nachlegen und hier schneller
ihnen das gelingt mit ihren
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern desto
mehr wird ihnen der dank und die
anerkennung gewiss sein meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren klima und
wirtschaft zu vereinen ist eine
notwendige aber keine leichte aufgabe
ich weiß wie das ist weil viele von
denen die sich seit jahren für
klimaschutz und ökologie und
nachhaltigkeit engagieren sagen das war
doch die wirtschaft die eigentlich dazu
beigetragen hat dass wir kosten extra
analysiert haben und auf kosten der
umwelt profite und gewinne realisiert
wurden warum sollen wir jetzt auf die
interessen der wirtschaft rücksicht
nehmen aber war es eben auch dass nur
mit einer funktionierenden wirtschaft
die umwelt und klimaschäden der
vergangenheit wieder ausgeglichen und
wieder gut gemacht werden können war es
auch dass nur mit einer
funktionierenden wirtschaft auch
ökologische moderne ökologische politik
bildungspolitik sozialpolitik möglich
ist dass ist das ökologische ökonomische
paradox dass aufzulösen ist eine große
herausforderung aber sie ist nicht
unmöglich zu schaffen wir haben ist in
vielen bereichen in der vergangenheit
gesehen ich möchte aber nicht mit
ungebetenen ratschlag gegen den betrieb
im ministerium aufrechterhalten ich weiß
über robert habeck sie finden eine
mannschaft vor die bereit ist mit ihnen
ihren staatssekretären und ihren
vertrauten fair und konstruktiv zu
arbeiten
ihre führung wahrzunehmen und darauf
auch zu antworten dass waren auch für
mich nicht immer leichte aufgaben weil
natürlich eine verwaltung auch eigene
vorstellungen hat und es ist ihr gutes
recht dafür zu kämpfen aber der minister
ist derjenige der entscheidet und
deshalb lieber robert habeck ich wünsche
ihnen und ihren mitarbeitern eine gute
hand machen sie es gut und besser ich
habe eben ein kleines buch mitgebracht
von karl schlögel im raume lesen wir die
zeit das ist philosophisch aber man hat
mir gesagt sie sind eines
intellektuellen gedankens fähig und ich
habe mich davon schon oft überzeugt
insofern wenn sie mal nachts nicht
schlafen können wegen der vielen
probleme nehmen sie das buch zur hand
und ich wünsche ihnen eine fantastische
zeit und dass sie irgendwann dieses haus
wieder verlassen in dankbarkeit so wie
ich für alle die mich unterstützt haben
und in zufriedenheit darüber dass es
möglich war schritte in die richtige
richtung zu gehen alles alles gute und
viel erfolg
war es doch eine etwas umfangreichere
längere abschiedsrede von peter altmaier
dem bisherigen wirtschaftsminister er
übergibt das abend an robert abel der
nicht nur wirtschaftsminister sondern
auch minister für klimaschutz sein wird
sehr geehrter herr minister harbeck sehr
geehrter herr altmaier sehr geehrte frau
staatssekretärin sehr geehrte herren
staatssekretäre liebe herren beauftragte
und koordinatoren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
heute ist ein besonderer tag wir
verabschieden unsere bisherige leitung
und begrüßen herrn harbeck als minister
im neuen ministerium für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz
gern hätten wir dies wie in der
vergangenheit gemeinsam mit unseren
beschäftigten
vor ort getan denn bei aller
digitalisierung
persönliche kontakte lassen sich
manchmal nur schwer ersetzen aber
die pandemie lässt es eben nicht zu
lieber herr altmaier
sie haben dieses haus seit 20 18
geleitet und auch wenn wir
personalpolitisch nicht immer einer
meinung waren ihre politischen
verdienste sind unbestritten
sie sind seit 1994 mitglied des
deutschen bundestags gewesen sie waren
in fünf verschiedenen ressorts tätig und
sie haben sich den vielfältigsten
aufgaben gestellt
ihr wirken in diesem ministerium wurde
ganz wesentlich von corona bestimmt das
virus hat auch die wirtschaftspolitik
unseres landes sprichwörtlich
durcheinandergewirbelt viele
förderprogramme mussten praktisch über
das wochenende aufgesetzt werden in der
wirtschaft gab und gibt es große
zukunftsängste die sich eben auch im
alltag eines ministeriums niederschlagen
dies war eine besondere herausforderung
auch für eine so erfahrene leitung
jetzt beginnt für sie ein völlig neuer
lebensabschnitt
sie können morgens ihren kaffee trinken
ohne an die nächsten vorlagen und
termine zu denken sie können auf reisen
gehen oder es sich einfach mal gemütlich
machen
das wird ihn vielleicht am anfang gar
nicht so leicht fallen
trotzdem hoffe ich dass sie die neue
freiheit genießen werden
liebe frau winkelmeier-becker liebe
herren parlamentarische staatssekretäre
liebe beauftragte und koordinatoren
auch ihnen gebührt großer dank für ihr
engagement in den letzten jahren die
meisten haben sich entschieden
wieder für den bundestag zu kandidieren
und sie waren erfolgreich
hier zu gratulieren wir ihnen herzlich
wie werden sie sicherlich in den
nächsten jahren gelegentlich im
bundestag auch wieder treffen
liebe frau der fonds
lieber herr nußbaum lieber herr frei
[Applaus]
es war der amtsübergabe ich glaube wir
haben da gerade ein technisches problem
gesehen gehört ganz genau ich
wir sind jetzt aber ich höre schon das
ist also wie gesagt es war die
amtsübergabe von peter altmaier an
robert habeck wir hatten gerade ein
technisches problem und wir sind jetzt
live drauf sie sehen es ist das
verteidigungsministerium er übergibt
annegret kramp karrenbauer
ihren staffelstab sozusagen an christine
lambrecht und da gehen wir jetzt live
drauf
mehr
wow
[Musik]
hier besprochen wird von den fans
so wir sehen hier gerade wir sind hier
live in berlin es geht um die
amtsübergabe im
bundesverteidigungsministerium
christine lambrecht die neue
verteidigungsministerin und annegret
kramp karrenbauer ja wir sehen hier die
kollegen das ist alles sehr ein bisschen
hektisch dann wackelt das bild das ist
eben so bei solchen statements heute
nachmittag und jetzt
ja ich versuche gerade mal was zu
erkennen
müsste eigentlich ein statement kommen
genau und wir schauen mal live dazu in
berlin
ja also im moment muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen
gucken wir mal bis der nächste
redebeitrag beginnt wie gesagt das ist
die amtsübergabe im verteidigungsressort
und wir waren ja kurz vorher im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium da hat sich
peter altmaier sehr umfangreich sehr
menschlich so wie man ihn halt kennt von
seinem mitarbeiterstab verabschiedet
manche haben vielleicht noch auf die
rede von robert habeck gewartet ich höre
gerade wir kommen wieder zurück nach
bonn bei uns im studio wir haben in
berlin paar technische probleme aber ich
muss ihnen sagen das müssen wir an
diesem tag entschuldigen wo die
amtsübergabe einfach ineinander
übergreifen vielleicht mal ganz kurz
hier bei uns im studio professor tilman
mayer ja also peter altmaier hat sich
sehr umfänglich verabschiedet man kennt
ihn ja dass er menschlich sehr kollegial
sein soll robert habe kam war leider
nicht gehört aber wir haben von robert
habe ich schon gehört dass dieses neue
ministerium dieses superministerium er
ist ja auch vizekanzler in der neuen
ampel von wirtschaft und klima er hat
gesagt der klimawandel ohne zumutungen
wird das nicht gehen ja und der amt der
ehemalige minister hat natürlich der
fahnung altmaier war ja umweltminister
insofern will kommt er mit dem thema
sehr gut zurecht klima und wirtschaft
insofern hat er dann auch sagen können
glaubhaft dass da eine gewisse
vorbereitung stattfindet und
stattgefunden hat im ministerium
von daher sind war das natürlich auch
von seiner seite aus muss nur sagen eine
abschiedsrede nicht nur als minister
sondern auch vor was seine politische
laufbahn angeht er hat ja auf das mandat
verzichtet im bundestag
jetzt dann sozusagen in dem freiwillig
gewählten ruhestand und wird sich damit
oder von bismarck zum beispiel
beschäftigen was bisher auch schon seine
leidenschaft war oder mit anderen dingen
hin falls das saarland wird ihn
wiederhaben aber ich kann jetzt noch
nicht genau ob er vielleicht auch in
berlin entsprechend dort hat er ja auch
zum zum essen oft nach hause eingeladen
der in seine bibliothek die sehr groß
ist und so weiter also da werden wir
ihnen noch wahrscheinlich hören oder
sehen ich höre hier gerade die neue
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht also jetzt gehen wir wieder
darüber nach berlin und wir hören mal zu
was sie zu sagen hat
das ist heute ein sehr besonderer tag
für mich und
das drückt sich auch in der besonderheit
der amtsübergabe aus mit militärischen
ehren
heute hier ins amt eingeführt zu werden
das ist natürlich eine besonderheit des
verteidigungsministeriums eine andere
besonderheit und für mich eben auch
große verantwortung ist dass die
befehls- und kommandogewalt über die
streitkräfte jetzt bei mir liegt und das
bedeutet verantwortung für über
260.000 menschen der bundeswehr
und was das bedeutet das ist mir
gestern gestern auf tragische weise
deutlich geworden als es bei einer übung
auf dem truppenübungsplatz bergen zu
einem unglück kam wir haben zwei
menschenleben zu beklagen
meine gedanken sind auch jetzt bei den
angehörigen die diesen schmerzlichen
verlust zu verkraften haben ich wünsche
in den viel stärke und kraft um die
dunklen stunden und tage zu durchstehen
diese schmerzlichen erfahrungen zu
amtsbeginn nehme ich aber als auftrag an
mich mit fürsorge mit fürsorge und
hinten gab um die menschen zu kümmern
die mir anvertraut sind in der
bundeswehr und dazu sind mir gespräche
mit besuchen bei der truppe bereits in
den nächsten tagen besonders wichtig ich
will erfahren wie die hier situation ist
ich möchte gerade mit blick auf die
auslandseinsätze erfahren was die
soldatinnen und soldaten bewegt wenn sie
den auftrag ausführen den der dem ihnen
das parlament gegeben hat und dabei leib
und leben gefährden und das ist wichtig
zu wissen was in den soldatinnen und
soldaten vorgeht welche erfahrungen sie
gemacht haben damit ich mich dann hier
im inneren
für sie engagieren kann
dass ich im politischen raum dann ganz
konsequent auch für die zentralen
belange der truppe einstehen kann
eine aufgabe die vielfältiger kaum sein
könnte ich bin mir der verantwortung der
herausforderung durchaus bewusst aber
ich nehme sie gerne an und danke ihnen
für die aufmerksamkeit
ja soweit die neue
bundesverteidigungsminister in lambrecht
von der spd vielleicht können wir noch
mal mit unserem korrespondenten in
berlin sprechen mit gerd joachim von
fallois ganz genau also christine
lambrecht mancher hatte sie vielleicht
schon als innenministerin gesehen sie
war vielleicht selber ein bisschen
überrascht ich meine justizministerin
dann hat sie das amt der
familienministerin
nach übernommen sie hat auch diese woche
gesagt bei ihrem amtsantritt also sie
liebt herausforderungen sie steht dazu
und ich sag mal so sie ist bis jetzt ja
immer durchgekommen und wichtig wird
natürlich seien die anerkennung bei der
truppe diese jetzt kriegt sie braucht
ja christine lambrecht ist auch eine
überraschung im kabinett scholz nicht
dass sie in diesem kabinett auftaucht
sondern dass die bundes
verteidigungsministerin wird das hatte
vorher auch kaum einer erwartet
christine lambrecht 56 jahre alt war mal
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der spd
bundestagsfraktion
dort ist er gar nicht aufgefallen sage
ich mal höflich und dann wurde sie
ministerin und eine sehr gute denn es
ist ja so wenn man ein ministerium
übernimmt dann muss man vor allen dingen
sich auch mit den beamten befassen und
deren expertise nutzen und christian
bericht hat es schnell verstanden das
justizministerium zu leiten eigene
akzente zu setzen die minister liege
dort richtig einzusetzen auch dann nicht
später als familienministerin und jetzt
eben bundesverteidigungsminister das ist
auch deshalb etwas überraschen weil
christine lambrecht selber im sommer
angekündigt habe dass sie sich
zurückziehen wird
sie ist 256 aber sie wollte sich
eigentlich aus der politik zurückziehen
sie hat ja auch nicht wieder für den
deutschen bundestag kandidiert naja und
als dann olaf scholz die wahl gewonnen
hatte dann wurde nicht nur ihr sondern
auch olaf scholz klar er braucht frauen
für die ämter und dann hat christine
lambrecht sich überreden lassen nun also
ihr großer respekt vor diesem amt das
kann man verstehen das
verteidigungsministerium ist auch immer
so ein bisschen ein schleudersitz da gab
es schon den ein oder anderen
spektakulären rücktritt ich nenne nur
mal rudolf scharping der damen einst
einstmals sogar entlassen wurde also da
ist nur schwer staat zu machen und als
frau ohnehin die letzten zwei amtschefin
waren auch frauen und ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ob der eine oder andere
offizier sagt nun schon wieder eine frau
sie selber hat ja gesagt dass sie sich
da erstmal eingewöhnen muss und so ist
es wohl auch und der staat das hat sich
auch erwähnt mit einem unglücksfall ist
alles andere als schön und was ich
gerade rudolf scharping gesagt ich kann
mich erinnern an 1998 99 der
kosovo-krieg rudolf schabbing damals
noch die hardthöhe übrigens das
verteidigungsministerium auf der
hardthöhe liegt ja eigentlich in bonn
das war hier der winter bock der
berliner bereich also rudolf scharping
der damalige verteidigungsminister
stand jeden morgen zu einer
pressekonferenz bereit und war immer
sehr sehr nervös er hatte große sorge
und das kann man verstehen dass zink
sage nach hause kam es ist für einen
verteidigungsminister in der tat eines
der schwersten dinge wenn dann soldaten
gefallen sind hier hatte sich gestern um
einen unglücksfall gehandelt und wenn
ich noch eins sagen darf annegret kramp
karrenbauer ist mir heute schon im
parlament nicht aufgefallen auch hier
nicht dass es ungewöhnlich gewesen
es kann sein dass sie vielleicht gar
nicht da war heute sie kriegt jedenfalls
wie das üblich ist einen großen
zapfenstreich in der kommenden woche
natürlich wir haben uns auch gerade
gefragt bei den bildern es war ja alles
live wo es eigentlich annegret
kramp-karrenbauer das war die große
frage wir warten jetzt gerd vielleicht
kommen wir dazu noch was sagen gerade
auf die amtsübergabe im
bundesgesundheitsministerium
er übergibt jens spahn sein haus an karl
lauterbach den neuen gesundheitsminister
vielleicht können sie uns noch mal so
sagen wie die reaktion in berlin waren
dass es nun doch geworden ist denn so
viele wollten also durchweg positiv
wirklich so quer durch die fraktionen
interessanterweise hat ja die csu markus
söder schon in der vergangenen woche
vehement karl lauterbach gefordert er
gehört zur abteilung vorsicht das wird
auch der grund sein warum markus söder
dass so getan hat aber ich habe heute
mit mehreren parametern reden können die
gesagt haben das ist prima dass der das
macht mit einer einschränkung karl
lauterbach ist er so ein ein mann
betrieb
und er geht ja nicht ins auswärtige amt
wohl nicht viele leute mitbringen kann
er braucht eine mannschaft auf um sich
herum und da bezweifeln viele ob karl
lauterbach der richtige ist ein
ministerium zu führen aber das kann eben
keiner beurteilen bevor herr lauda war
nicht damit angefangen hat und wir gehen
jetzt einfach mal davon aus dass karl
lauterbach dieses ministerium gut führen
wird auch sich auf mitarbeiter stützen
kann so ist das eigentlich üblich und
man muss jedem neuen minister natürlich
erst mal die chance geben so ein
ministerium zu übernehmen und sich dann
dort einzurichten in der tat dadurch
auch durch seine vielen fernsehauftritte
ist es natürlich einfach zu sagen karl
lauterbach ist ein einzelgänger aber ich
kenne ihn auch schon ein paar jahre
länger auch in der spd
bundestagsfraktion
er war tatsächlich immer ein bisschen so
ein einzelgänger hatte häufig eine
andere meinung als viele in der spd auch
gerade zu gesundheitsfragen wo er
natürlich auch experte ist aber ich kann
mich zum beispiel an heiner geißler bei
der cdu erinnern das ist nun schon lange
her aber auch einer geißler der lange
jahre auch generalsekretär von helmut
kohl war war vor allen dingen in seinen
letzten jahren eher heiner geißler und
nicht so sehr die cdu und ich will nicht
sagen dass das bei einer lauterbach auch
so ist aber er ist schon ein highlight
als aussteller versprecher bei karl
lauterbach aus so ist aber er ist schon
jemand der tatsächlich viel für sich
selber liest er arbeitet mit
wissenschaftlern spricht vor ort ist in
fernsehstudios und weniger derjenige der
in parteigliederungen bei langen
diskussionen teilnimmt und sich dort
quasi in den letzten jahren aufgehalten
hätte ja das ist ja auch nicht so
schlecht dass mal ein experte gerade an
diesem heiklen ministerium ich denke mal
er wird die 100 tage einarbeitungszeit
ja nicht kriegen er wird sofort zeigen
müssen was er kann ich meine die meldung
heute sind ja wieder dass zum beispiel
die ärzte sagen es ist immer noch nicht
genug doch da obwohl das jens spahn also
der scheidende bundesgesundheitsminister
letzte woche ja immer wieder dementiert
hat also karl lauterbach wird sofort
loslegen müssen zusammen mit den ländern
es gibt ja morgen auch die nächste
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ja wir warten jetzt gerade noch auf die
amtsübergabe ich frag mal weiter hier
tilman mayer politologe professor von
der universität in bonn das ist
natürlich in anspruch aber ich denke mal
dass auch jemand der als einzelkämpfer
bekannt ist natürlich in seinem
ministerium weiß ich habe meinen
mitarbeiterstab und das kann ja auch mal
von vorteil sein dass jemand nicht
parteipolitisch so eingebunden ist
sondern sich mehr auf die sache
konzentriert naja ich schon
parteipolitisch auch eingebundene hat
das war ja auch eine frage wer dann
abschneiden wird er ist hat ja sehr gut
abgeschnitten insofern bei der
bundestagswahl insofern war es natürlich
auch eine parteiliche unterstützung aber
ins amt gekommen scheint so zu sein ist
er aufgrund der von von volkes meinung
ja also das waren starker trieb in das
amt was da einzog sozusagen
und er wurde ja auch ganz zum schluss
erst gefragt muss man hat man gelesen
insofern war das nicht zur ersten wahl
für den er kann sehr viel ende kann ich
vielleicht erzählen hat unserem reporter
vorhin in berlin gesagt sie ist für
ungefähr 14 tagen befragt worden von den
grünen ich denke mal bei lauterbach wird
das sehr kurzfristig gewesen sein da ist
am sonntag habe ich gewesen insofern
also was ich der der jetzige kanzlerin
nicht so ganz sicher aber das sich traut
entsprechend es gab nie andere nahmen
die entsprechend genannt wurden auch von
frauen und insofern glaube ich ist da
aber
stolz da doch etwas gelungen was man
eben vielleicht gar nicht so zugedreht
hat das hat er hier rücksicht nimmt aber
er hatte vielleicht könnte man so
zuspitzen sagen gar keine andere wahl
als diese option zu nehmen was man weiß
ist natürlich so dass das
er tatsächlich ein ein sehr großes
ministerium noch nicht geleitet hat
insofern wird es eine herausforderung
aufgrund seiner seines seines auftretens
kann man sich das denken dass da
vielleicht gewisse schwierigkeit
entstehen wird man kann nur hoffen dass
die umgebungen da ein bisschen einfängt
und und im spiel räumen lässt er ist so
ein bisschen wie in einem großen
unternehmen der ideengeber und man
braucht eben leute die operativ tätig
sind also das sollte man trennen und
wenn wenn diese lösung gelingt dass er
hat sozusagen die richtige spur hat aber
die anderen sie verfolgen können dann
wird da aus diesem laden ganz in eine
interessante angelegenheit und kriegen
wir diese welle er sagt immer wir müssen
vor die welle kommen also er muss als
erster das sozusagen vor dem m springen
und sagen wie man die entsprechende
anhält dieses versprechen hat er
eigentlich gegeben ein bisschen kühl
aber das ist natürlich die
erwartungshaltung wir haben ja vor allem
von den 100 tagen gesprochen also bis
weihnachten sag ich mal könnte da
vielleicht schon ein gewisser effekt
entstehen die hoffnung oder erwartung
gehen jedenfalls in diese richtung
es ist nicht nur das
gesundheitsministerium es ist das
verteidigungsministerium es ist das
wirtschafts- und klimaministerium man
möchte eigentlich fast fragen welches
ministerium nicht da ist sehr viel aber
es ist nicht so dass vorher schlecht
regiert wurde sondern es ist einfach da
sind die zeitumstände die tatsächlich
erfordern dass hier entsprechend agiert
wird insofern sind diese spielräume der
des gemütlichen anfangs einfach nicht
gegeben ich gucke mal gerade nach berlin
wir warten immer noch gern von fall war
mein kollege ich würde mal fragen wie
sind denn zum beispiel so die
erwartungen ich denke mal das wird ja
bald die erste pressekonferenz geben wo
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach mit
lothar wieler zusammentrifft ja was
hören sie denn so aus den politischen
reihen wie sind da so die erwartungen
die man hat wenn er sein amt antritt und
ja
das schöne ist ja dass die haltung von
karl lauterbach zu der ganzen pandemie
frage allen bürgern in diesem land
bekannt ist durch seine vielen auftritte
und diese haltung war auf dem
bundeskanzler bekannt sicherlich nicht
unangenehm für olaf scholz die haltung
von einem lauterbach allerdings ist ein
grund warum karl lauterbach erst sehr
spät gefragt wurde unter anderem und das
darf man nie vergessen auch ein proporz
grund erstens wollte olaf scholz am
liebsten eine frau haben und zum zweiten
stammt svenja schulze auch aus nordrhein
westfalen und bei sieben ministern dann
zwei aus nordrhein westfalen dann muss
man immer ein bisschen auf den proporz
gucken auch wenn es ein bisschen lustig
klingt nach dem die grünen gestern zum
beispiel drei frauen aus nordrhein
westfalen an die fraktionsspitze gewählt
haben aber es spielt schon eine rolle
auch in einem kabinett auch in einer
großen partei wie der spd da wollen sich
die landesverbände wiederfinden und das
war auch ein grund warum karl lauterbach
zunächst nicht sofort gefragt wurde aber
der hauptgrund ist sicherlich dass er
ein einzelkämpfer war bislang und ab
heute darf er das nicht mehr sein da
muss ja der teamplayer sein da muss er
vorne spielen und hinter sich die
mannschaft versammeln und ich denke mal
dass karl lauterbach vom fachlichen
optimal aufgestellt ist und ein
ministerium zu leiten das müssen
übrigens viele von den anderen ministern
auch erst lernen das würde dann schon
lernen wenn er die richtigen mitarbeiter
an seiner seite haben sollte ja und der
hat natürlich professor meyer eine sehr
große aufgabe auch mit der impfpflicht
kommen soll wir haben ja erst mal die
impfpflicht für berufe im pflegeheim und
den kliniken und dann die allgemeine
impfpflicht über die abgestimmt werden
sollen bundes wir müssen natürlich sehen
dass er auch wie alle minister
beziehungsweise wie allzu viele
politiker auch massive massiven
gegenwind hat auch persönliche
herausforderungen gibt es da immer mehr
braucht polizeischutz und so weiter also
all diese dinge muss müssen mitgedacht
werden aber wenn er liefert wenn
sozusagen
eine wende eintritt gewisser weise in
der der pandemie front dann ist er
natürlich der mann der stunde insofern
muss man mal sehen was möglich ist ja
ich habe gerade gehört wir sehen sie
auch ein bild der frühere
bundesgesundheitsminister
jens spahn ist da auch lothar wieler der
lka-chef ja herr professor meyer weil
sie das gerade gesagt haben diese
persönlichen anfeindungen und ich habe
heute zum beispiel noch gelesen also
nicht nur vor dem haus der sächsischen
gesundheitsministerin petra köpping
wurde demonstriert von hasserfüllten
leuten sondern es waren auch bei karl
lauterbach an seinem wohnhaus ist das
vorletzte woche auch passiert dass der
korona gegner demonstriert haben eine
unsägliche entwicklung so jetzt warten
wir im bundesgesundheitsministerium
weiterhin auf die amtsübergabe jens
spahn geht karl lauterbach kommt und
auch sie werden sich hier in
persönlichen kurzen reden äußern
ja vielleicht kann man noch mal ganz
kurz sagen herr professor meyer so die
bilanz von jens spahn ja ist ja
eigentlich ganz gut gestartet wie fällt
denn ihr resümee aus also wenn man ihn
so vor die presse treten sieht und was
ihr da äußert im
mit dem tenor der der überzeugung dass
es nur so richtig sein kann dann denkt
man es war alles in ordnung aber im
nachhinein und bei verschiedenen
aussagen die er gemacht hat war nennen
einfach sozusagen defizite ganz klar da
die sich zunächst mal von ihm verbal
nicht mitgeteilt wurden insofern waren
es oft schlingerkurses die sich da
abzeichnet aber er hatte natürlich auch
ein sehr undankbarer job muss man sagen
und sich da in diesem job überhaupt so
lange zu halten unter diesen umständen
war schon eine herausforderung
insofern mit zeit mit zeitlichem abstand
wird man schon sagen können dass dann
eine leistung dahinter steckt und auch
eine affinität zu dem thema die ja
vorher auch schon hatte insofern so
waren wir nicht so schlecht bedient wie
das sich
schwieriges amt instanz schwierigen
zeiten der kirchen von verlor ich gebe
die frage mal gleich an sich weiter wir
haben hier luther wieder gesehen der
konnte vor wenigen wochen seinen unmut
nicht mehr zurückhalten und hat gesagt
salopp formuliert es jetzt einfach mal
so ich komme mir vor wie ein papagei wie
wird denn die leistung von jens spahn in
der korona pandemie von der
hauptstadtpresse eingeschätzt
naja jens spahn ist in einer achterbahn
unterwegs gewesen vor knappen jahr war
der beliebteste politiker in den
umfragen in deutschland
deutschland stand sehr gut da in der
ersten welle dann hapert es an
verschiedenen dingen wo man auch immer
noch mal beleuchten muss war der
minister daran schuld woran hat es
gelegen im genauen aber das wurde
natürlich alles bei jens spahn abgeladen
ja und im moment ist er einfach sang-
und klanglos durchgereicht worden auch
in der beliebten sparen ist quasi an
allem schuld als minister ist es eben so
und das erträgt er auch ganz durch und
jetzt ist es 16 uhr man wartet auf karl
lauterbach das ist auch schon nach ein
guter beginn wie ich finde aber gut sei
es drum karl lauterbach übrigens wenn
sie sich erinnern vorhin im schloss
bellevue war der einzige politiker der
beim sitzen auf die maske auf hatten
robert habeck hat das dann auch getan
als er zu seinem sitz wieder
zurückgegangen ist aber daran sieht man
schon karl lauterbach ist derjenige der
die abteilung vorsicht vertritt und das
ist auch einer der gründe warum er von
corona leugnern sicherlich als einer der
haupt zielscheiben ausgemacht worden ist
und da kann man für karl lauterbach
jetzt nur im nachhinein sagen zum glück
ist er jetzt bundesminister da hat er
nämlich eine große sicherheits
mannschaft die ihn beschützen kann und
beschützen wird hoffentlich und dann ist
diese persönliche gefahr dieses
politikers etwas minimiert ja weil sie
das gerade sagen das ist schon mal ein
guter beginn sie warten hier alle wie
ist denn das bei solchen amtsübergabe
eigentlich ist man doch pünktlich oder
ja ich kann nicht sagen woran es liegt
dass karl lauterbach noch nicht
aufgetaucht ist aber ihren sparen
jedenfalls scheint noch die ruhe weg zu
haben und wartet hier im kreise seiner
ehemaligen mitarbeiter und lothar wieler
wie gesagt wird sich das schon mal
angucken er kennt ja kalt aber auch man
hat auch zu dritt wenn ich mich richtig
im sinne vor einigen monaten schon
einmal in der bundespressekonferenz über
diese schreckliche krankheit
auskunft gegeben also man kennt sich
natürlich gut der unterschied wird sein
dass die neue ampel regierung und karl
lauterbach vorneweg
andere bestimmung methoden jetzt
erarbeiten werden man wird ja eine
ständige expertenkommission im
bundeskanzleramt ansiedeln und nicht nur
auf das rkw hören das wird sicherlich
auch er weder bewerten für sich ob das
ein misstrauen ist will ich nicht sagen
aber man will es auf weitere auf weitere
schultern stellen und da ist jetzt karl
lauterbach tatsächlich der aufgetaucht
gehört war jahre wagen ja er ist jetzt
da und ich gehe mal davon aus dass es
demnächst auch losgehen wird vielleicht
ist das prozedere ja so wie bei den
anderen jens spahn übergibt und karl
lauterbach übernimmt dann einfach und
wir schauen jetzt mal begrüßt hier
seinen neuen kollegen ja
die fotos genau die fliege genau sie
sagen dass herr professor meyer die hat
man nicht mehr gesehen es hat sich auch
geändert jetzt wo sie sagen das ist
natürlich eine große veränderung ich
glaube so da ich würde sogar sagen seit
monaten haben
aber wie gesagt das sind nur
äußerlichkeiten
soeben
bundesgesundheitsministerium das
staffelstab wird übergeben jens spahn
von der cdu an karl lauterbach spd der
ihm im amt nachfolgt denkbar schwierigen
zeiten
bundesministerium für gesundheit
wir verabschieden heute unseren
ehemaligen bundesminister ihren sparen
und begrüßen sein nachfolger im amt herr
minister lauterbach wegen der pandemie
müssen wir das kann leider in etwas
kleinerem rahmen machen heute das hätte
einen größeren rahmen
verdient denn diese pandemie hat uns
großes abverlangt und ich denke ich
spreche da auch im namen der kolleginnen
und kollegen sie herr sparen haben
großes geleistet sie haben dieses land
durch diese pandemie geführt und sie
hätten sie hätten das land gerne aus der
pandemie herausgeführt
lauterbach sie übernehmen ein haus in
schwierigen zeiten dieses haus in
schwierigen zeiten aber das haus kann
krise
und weiß wie krise geht auf unseren
einsatz können sie sich verlassen ich
übergibt das wort an staatssekretär
steffen der eine rede hält herzlichen
dank
ist von jens spahn ja vielen dank herr
kautz eigentlich haben sie alles schon
gesagt in kurzform und das so
auszudrücken sehr geehrter herr minister
sparen ich weiß das sagt man ab heute
nicht mehr aber ich habe mich noch nicht
ganz daran gewöhnen können deshalb sehen
sie es mir nach sehr geehrter herr
minister lauterbach sehr geehrte frau
parlamentarische staatssekretärin der
parlamentarische staatssekretär lieber
kolleginnen kollegen für mich als
amtschef ist es eine besondere ehre
heute diese amtsübergabe zu eröffnen und
einige einleitende worte zu ihnen zu
sprechen
und ich sage auch ganz bewusst dass in
dem das wir alle gemeinsam ihnen alles
erdenklich gute wünschen für die
nächsten jahre die kommen im sinne
unseres landes insofern herzlichen
glückwunsch zur heutigen ernennung und
das haus wie haag ausgesagt hat steht
komplett hinter ihnen und ist bereit mit
ihnen gemeinsam diese pandemie zu
bekämpfen und auch zu beenden ich freue
mich sehr so viele kolleginnen kollegen
heute auch hier zu sehen ich freue mich
vor allem auch dass ich eine neue
kollegin bekomme als zweite
staatssekretärin im bundesministerium
für gesundheit frau antje draheim
wir konnten uns heute schon kurz
austauschen das ist eine kluge und gute
entwicklung die iren sparen und ich auch
angeregt haben weil die leistungsspanne
in diesem haus so groß geworden ist dass
wir glauben es braucht einen zweiten
staatssekretär eine zweite
staatssekretärin insofern glaube ich ist
das die absolut richtige entscheidung
für dieses haus insofern auch an sie ein
herzliches willkommen und das haus freut
sich auf sie und ich selbst werde gerne
darum hat mich minister lauterbach auch
gebeten noch einige wochen hier im und
weiter machen so dass wir dann in 20 22
einen geordneten übergang hinbekommen
ich glaube das ist angebracht in dieser
krise und dazu stehe ich natürlich auch
gerne bereit und als minister sparen und
wir alle dieses haus dann übernommen
haben ich ein jahr später erst vor
zweieinhalb jahren hatten wir
zugegebenermaßen noch etwas weniger
turbulente zeiten die turbulenz für uns
damals im jahr 2018 kam ins haus zum
teil natürlich durch den neuen minister
und wenn ich das so sagen darf ersparen
ich glaube sie haben das prinzip von
benjamin britten
berücksichtigt rudern ist ja oder lernen
ist wie rudern gegen den strom sobald
man aufhört dann treibt man zurück und
ich sage das ist ein gutes bild aus dem
ruder weil wir auch sehr bekannte
ruderer heute unter uns haben dass das
ein motto war für jan sparen der von
anfang an gesagt hat ich muss dinge
modernisieren ich muss dinge
vorantreiben und das haus hat das
freiwillig aufgenommen und sie
bestmöglich
unterstützt wenn ich das so ausdrücken
darf sie haben schon damals 2018 mehr
fortschritt gewagt für das
gesundheitswesen und das hat allen sehr
gut getan wir sind nicht am ende eines
prozesses wir sind mitten einen prozess
und dieser prozess muss weitergehen und
insofern war auch immer klar dass der
minister eine hohe taktzahl vorgegeben
hat wir haben auf monatsbasis
gesetzesentwürfe dem souveränen im
deutschen bundestag vorgeschlagen frau
widmer weiß worüber ich rede wir waren
alle auch ein stückchen
leidgeplagt und immer wenn wir dachten
hier in diesem hause wir schaffen das
kam das nächste paket und wenn das
nächste paket abgearbeitet habe
festgestellt jetzt steht wieder vor der
tür und dann haben wir uns auch immer
wieder gefragt schaffen wir das oder
schaffen wir das nicht bisher haben wir
das gut geschafft aber klar ist auch
dass diese herausforderung jetzt an sie
übergeben werden und als dann corona in
der ta tm bmg gemeistert werden musste
über lange lange monate da war auch klar
bevor wir den kollegen holte haben hier
ins haus geholt haben unser corona
general war von anfang an der minister
und er hat entscheidungen getroffen so
schnell wie ich das in der vergangenheit
kaum gesehen habe weil es notwendig war
geschwindigkeit zu machen in dieser
pandemie und insofern ein dankeschön
dafür dass sie so schnell und so viel
entschieden haben in dieser kürze der
zeit manchmal gar nicht richtig zeit zu
überlegen aber erst mal notwendig diese
entscheidungen zu treffen und insofern
erinnert mich manchmal diese
herausforderungen die wir heute noch
haben in dieser corona krise
an die erkenntnis wofür in dieser woche
der italienische physiker georgia paris
den physik nobelpreis bekommen hat er
hatte nämlich dafür bekommen das ist in
der physik manchmal einfache probleme
gibt die komplexe lösungen haben und das
ist glaube ich in dieser pandemie auch
ein bisschen so das einfache problem
dass wir kontakt beschränkungen oder
abstand einhalten müssen zwischen
menschen damit das virus nicht
überspringt erfordert komplexeste
lösungen weil in unserer gesellschaft
das nicht so einfach ist den menschen
voneinander abzuhalten zum kacken
kontakt abzuhalten und das ist glaube
ich auch heute noch die echte
herausforderung für einfache probleme
komplexer lösungen zu finden und auch
tatsächlich umzusetzen und deshalb der
minister laut aber auch diese einfachen
probleme sind jetzt ihre probleme sind
jetzt unsere probleme und deshalb habe
ich mir jetzt lange überlegt was gibt
man einem minister mit auf den weg der
einfache probleme aber durchaus sehr
harte und dicke nüsse zu knacken hat sie
brauchen einen instrumentenkasten der
ihnen ermöglicht sehr harte und dicke
nüsse zu knacken
ich erlaube mir mal
dafür das bestmögliche instrument mit
auf den weg zu geben
nämlich einen nussknacker aus deutscher
produktion
und ich sage ihnen ich habe lange
gesucht ich habe die härtesten und
größten müsse in ganz berlin dazu
ausgesucht und überreichte ihm das gerne
es ist alles desinfiziert und
zu achten auch die hygiene auflagen des
drk jeder können sie sicher sein wenn
ich das gleich tun darf
dann schließlich direkt an mit dem
hinweis dass ich eigentlich auch gerne
meinem ehemaligen minister ebenfalls ein
nussknacker geschenkt hätte weil er jede
menge müsse in der vergangenheit knacken
musste und sicherlich auch in der
zukunft noch knacken wird ich würde
trotzdem gerne ersparen davon absehen
und ich erkläre auch gerne warum ich
glaube dass ein neuer minister diese
harten nüsse nur knacken wird können
zusammen mit dem haus und deshalb
verdient nicht der ehemalige minister
sondern das bmg den zweiten akt weil der
minister alleine diese müsse nicht wird
meistern können deshalb erlaube ich mir
auch
dem bmg und allen kolleginnen und
kollegen einen zweiten acker zu
studieren und zwar einen berliner
feuerwehr warum meine damen und herren
wir sind übrigens übergabe im
bundesgesundheitsministerium hohe
wertigkeit monate ausgezahlt karl
lauterbach hat schon einmal bekommen ich
machen müssen dazu jens spahn bekommt
einen wir sehen das an diesem nachmittag
jedes ministerium macht die amtsübergabe
nach seinem eigenen gusto und ich hoffe
dass jetzt gleich so wie es die anderen
auch gemacht haben der bisherige
minister jens spahn spricht von der cdu
und danach der amtsnachfolger
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ja also wie gesagt das ist
die amtsübergabe in berlin im
bundesgesundheitsministerium
unseres knacker aus deutscher produktion
ich nehme mal an sie kommen vielleicht
aus dem erzgebirge
genau aus dass zur verfügung steht und
sie aktiv unterstützen wird lassen sie
mich ja vielleicht noch mal ganz ruhig
sagt joachim von fallois ballistik rat
noch sehe hier in unserem fenster was
man nach berlin aufgenommen ein bisschen
sparen denn dann kommt und dran ist mit
seinem redebeitrag jens spahn wie wird's
denn für ihn weitergehen was plant er
denn in zukunft
zunächst ist er bundestagsabgeordneter
und das wird er sicherlich auch bleiben
die frage die man sich vorstellen kann
ist bleibt er das auch über ein jahr
hinaus oder wechselt er dann wie seine
beiden vorgänger im amt des
gesundheitsministers irgendwann rüber in
die wirtschaft sie haben wir vielleicht
auch gelesen dass er sich ein ziemlich
teures haus zugelegt hat und ich kann
mir schon vorstellen dass da auch die
finanzen drücken und es gibt durchaus
die überlegung dass sie entspannen dann
eines tages in die wirtschaft abwandern
wird kontakte hat er genügend er muss
halt nur dieses jahr dazwischen
verbringen und in diesem jahr wird ja
auch weil sie darauf anspielen natürlich
die entscheidungen in der cdu fallen wer
dort neuer vorsitzender wird und jens
spahn von einem jahr noch der
beliebteste deutsche politiker
ist mittlerweile ein bisschen
durchgereicht worden ob da noch platz
für ihn ist das wage ich doch zu
bezweifeln jetzt kriegt also hier
erlaubt aber seinen nussknacker von dr
thomas steffen das ist der
staatssekretär im gesundheitsministerium
die auch noch einmal gesagt hat dass
auch der scheidende minister eigentlich
so einen verdient hätte aber er hat die
bahn-tochter indien und jetzt sparen
sehr geehrter herr minister lauterbach
meine damen und herren staatssekretäre
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren als sich
am 14 märz 2018 hier mit hermann gröhe
stand um das amt von ihm zu übernehmen
waren herdenimmunität
aerosolen kreuz impfungen selbst das
wort pandemie worte die vor allem nur
experten kann heute kennt das ganze land
diese worte was wir seit zwar fast zwei
jahren erleben nicht nur in deutschland
sondern weltweit das war damals
die allermeisten
unvorstellbar die amtsübergabe heute
spiegelt wider was sich verändert hat es
werden keine hände geschüttelt sondern
abstand gehalten und masken getragen
und normalerweise kann ein neuer
gesundheitsminister auf eine phase der
einarbeitung eine kurze schonfrist
hoffen normal ist aber gerade gar nichts
wir befinden uns in einer nationalen
notlage wie wir sie seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg nicht mehr erlebt haben
wahrscheinlich
fand noch keine amtsübergabe hier im
bundesministerium für gesundheit unter
so schwierigen bedingungen statt
in der aktuellen lage steht dieses
ministerium mehr im fokus denn je die
mutationen des virus zeigen wir sind
noch mitten in der pandemie
daher ist es gut dass diese zeit des
übergangs zwischen zwei regierungen nun
vorbei ist dass mein nachfolger heute
übernimmt
das gesundheitsressort traditionell
nicht zu den ressorts wie glanz und
gloria für den amtsinhaber
versprechen viel feind wenig er oder wie
eine unserer vorgängerin ulla schmidt
mal sagte als gesundheitsminister hat
man schnell die torten im gesicht
in den vergangenen dreieinhalb jahren
durfte ich aber erleben es ist ein
schönes ein wichtiges ressort so habe
ich es immer gesehen das sage ich ganz
bewusst auch in dieser situation ich
beschäftige mich seit fast 20 jahren mit
gesundheitspolitik ich habe es immer als
große und sinnstiftende aufgabe
empfunden
für die gesundheitsversorgung von über
80 millionen bürgerinnen und bürgern zu
kämpfen jeden tag zu arbeiten ein
unterschied zu machen in ihrem alltag
mit dem was wir hier entscheiden und
anstoßen und ebenso auch mich für gute
arbeitsbedingungen für die mehr als fünf
millionen
menschen einzusetzen die jeden tag bei
uns im gesundheitswesen arbeiten
meine zeit unsere zeit hier im
bundesministerium für gesundheit war
eine intensive zeit
schon vor der pandemie fast im
monatstakt haben wir hier im haus
gesetze gemacht
und nun seid bei zwei jahren haben wir
in einem ausnahmezustand agiert
wir haben wichtige modernisierungen
angestoßen vor allem in der
digitalisierung und sie kommen nun
endlich auch im versorgungsalltag an wir
haben hier viele verkrustungen
aufgebrochen und die pandemie hat uns
gezeigt wie wichtig das gehört in diesem
bereich ist und ohne frage das ist ja
auch das vorhaben müssen wir diesen weg
weitergehen
auch in der pflege haben wir viel bewegt
im übrigen auch gemeinsam in der großen
koalition viel bewegt die herausnahme
der pflege aus den fallpauschalen
bessere bezahlung mehr stellen
die auswirke auswirkungen der
jahrzehntelang strukturellen missachtung
dieses unverzichtbaren berufes sind
weiterhin spürbar aber die
abwärtsspirale
die konnten wir zumindest stoppen und
beginnen in die andere richtung zu
drehen natürlich reicht das nicht reicht
das gerade angesichts der aktuellen
situation nicht die pflege bleibt eine
wenn ich die große aufgabe der 20er
jahre
doch mit blick auf die aktuelle
situation was mich am meisten
erschüttert das sind die erzählung von
pflegekräften auf intensivstationen die
sich buchstäblich aufreiben um das leben
auch von ungeimpften patienten mit
kurven 19 zu retten die gleichzeitig
dann nicht selten den sinn dieser
impfung anzweifeln totale erschöpfung
und verzweiflung damit müssen
pflegekräfte wie ärztinnen und ärzte in
diesem moment oftmals ganz alleine
klarkommen
so ich höre gerade doch sind wir wieder
drei jahren durch diese blockierten
computer wir sind wie das album berlin
wenn wir nach und in dieser pandemie
nicht gelernt haben diesen beruf nicht
auch dauerhaft zu wertzuschätzen und im
übrigen damit auch dauerhaft zu bezahlen
und auszustatten wie es nötig ist eine
wäre uns tatsächlich nicht mehr zu
helfen
meine damen und herren mein besonderer
dank gilt allen kolleginnen und kollegen
hier im bundesministerium für gesundheit
und in den behörden unseres
geschäftsbereichs wie es formal heißt
im robert koch institut dem
paul-ehrlich-institut
im bv und auch in der bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung ohne sie
wären all die vorhaben dieser legislatur
nicht möglich gewesen vom staatssekretär
bis zum sachbearbeiter vom ministerbüro
bis zur forte ich danke ihnen für ihre
loyalität
ihren unermüdlichen einsatz
ihre kompetenz und ihren teamgeist
es war ein gutes gefühl im team bmg als
teamleiter und als außenverteidiger
mitmachen zu dürfen
sie alle haben mir in schwierigen zeiten
mit rat und tat zur seite gestanden mich
unterstützt und nicht damit wissen
lassen dass wir an einem strang ziehen
und gerade in den letzten zwei jahren
war die arbeitsbelastung enorm
in diesem ministerium brannte bis spät
nachts das licht
schalteten sich mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter regelmäßig am wochenende zu
sitzungen zusammen
alles damit wir als land gut durch diese
pandemie kommen können ich möchte ihnen
ausdrücklich meinen respekt und meine
anerkennung für ihre eindrucksvollen
leistungen und auch ihr
durchhaltevermögen aussprechen
und geben sie bitte diesen dank auch an
ihre familien weiter die diese belastung
mitgetragen haben
die wahrheit ist dass dieses ressort das
bundesministerium für gesundheit für
eine solche pandemie nicht ausgelegt war
dies ist eigentlich ein ministerium für
gesetzgebung
90 prozent wenn nicht mehr dessen was
wir eigentlich tun dass gesetze machen
anders als ein innen oder ein
verteidigungsministerium verfügen wir
nicht wirklich über operative einheiten
und doch war in den letzten zwei jahren
der pandemie das operative im
vordergrund beatmungsgeräte massentests
medikamente und impfstoffe beschaffen
den gesundheitsämtern der länder und
kommunen vor ort maßnahmen abstimmen
krisenstäbe gründen und leiten
in normalen zeiten würde man für jede
dieser aufgaben neue behörden oder neue
abteilungen gründen aber dafür war
schlecht keine zeit nur dank ihres
außergewöhnlichen einsatzes konnte es
überhaupt funktionieren und es hat ja
funktioniert das war es was zu beginn
knapp war ist nun mehr als genug da auch
impfstoffe gestern er es in brüssel beim
gesundheitsminister treffen sagte noch
ein beteiligter kollege zu mir ohne die
deutsche hartnäckigkeit im sommer
letzten jahres hätte es wahrscheinlich
ein vertrag der eu mit pfizer bayern
technisch gegeben wahrscheinlich
jedenfalls nicht rechtzeitig
auch läuft die aktuelle booster kampagne
und auch dort hat das ministerium alle
die jeden tag mit arbeiten in den
letzten zwei wochen noch mal ein
unterschied gemacht weiter gut an es ist
genug impfstoff da aktuell impft auch in
absoluten zahlen kein land der welt mehr
als deutschland zeigen sie mir einen
gesundheitswesen auf der welt das in
gleicher geschwindigkeit so schnell eine
solche impfkampagne so hochfahren kann
sie herr lauterbach werden das gesetzte
ziel von 30 millionen impfungen bis
jahresende erreichen und das ist gut für
unser land
eins ist mir
besonders wichtig es ist vieles gelungen
aber ich habe in dieser pandemie auch
manches falsch eingeschätzt auch fehler
gemacht
wir haben hier immer nach bestem wissen
und gewissen gehandelt und entschieden
wir hatten nicht das privileg
es im nachhinein doch schon vorher
gewusst zu haben
denn wir mussten in der situation
entscheiden und da großer unsicherheit
und mit vielen unwägbarkeiten
es war die bisher größte aufgabe meines
lebens mit allen höhen mit allen tiefen
und dennoch würde ich keinen tag
tauschen wollen
allerdings würde ich mit dem wissen von
heute manches anders entscheiden manches
anders kommunizieren ja bei der nächsten
pandemie wirst dich manches besser zu
machen
ich habe letztes jahr im april gesagt
wir werden in ein paar monaten
wahrscheinlich viel einander verzeihen
müssen das geld damals das gilt heute
noch ich bin sicher das wird auch noch
in vielen monaten gelten
meine damen und herren aus den
erfahrungen des vergangenen jahres kann
ich sicher sagen die arbeit hier im
bundesministerium für gesundheit ist
relevant für die geschicke unseres
landes unser ressort hat an bedeutung
hinzugewonnen und das wird bleiben
der bedeutungsgewinn spiegelt sich auch
in der personalentwicklung wieder lange
gehalten wir immer als kleines haus zu
meinem amtsantritt im märz 2018 hatte
das bundesministerium für gesundheit
rund 750 beschäftigte
heute haben wir weit über 1000 dieses
gewicht wird bleibt
denn gesundheit wird einen anderen
stellenwert haben das ist eine lehre die
wir als gesellschaft aus der pandemie
ziehen müssen unser gesundheitswesen ist
mit blick auf die individuelle
gesundheitliche versorgung
hervorragend eines der besten der welt
in bezug auf katastrophenvorsorge und
öffentliche gesundheit müssen wir aber
besser werden bei manchen stellen uns
auch neu ausstellen mit einem
aufgewerteten öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst mit einer nationalen
reserve gesundheitsschutz mit neuen
strukturen zwischen bund und ländern
dazu gehört dass wir ein neues
verständnis auch von krisenhaften lagen
entwickeln das von der gesamten
gesellschaft getragen wird
denn wir haben in dieser krise in der
öffentlichen debatte diese krise nie
wirklich als das angenommen was sie ist
eine existenzielle herausforderung die
uns zwingt schnell zu reagieren immer
der lage angepasst
eine lage aber die sich beständig ändert
und dynamisch ist in debatten lässt sich
leicht abstrakt fordern vorausschauend
zu handeln
konkret ist das bei sich beständig
ändernde bedingungen manchmal schon was
anderes
lieber herr minister lauterbach 2013 als
wir beide federführend den gesundheits
teil der damals werden in großen
koalition verhandelt hatten den damals
größten politischen streitpunkt übrigens
zwischen union und spd und das zur
überraschung der meisten auch noch
geräuschlos und erfolgreich da waren wir
beide fest davon überzeugt dass einer
von uns beiden gesundheitsminister würde
es kam anders
nun sind wir ist doch beide geworden
hintereinander unter anderem trotz
anderen vielleicht sogar wegen der
anderen bedingungen
ein regierungswechsel ist eine zäsur es
ist ein neuanfang ich wünsche mir dass
dieser moment genutzt wird lassen sie
uns alle über die eigene haltung und die
eigenen argumente neu nachdenken den
kopf aus der eigenen babbel der eigenen
debatten blase hervorheben und breit
informieren
auch über die lage und die argumente
andersdenkender es ist jetzt
ein moment dazu denn es ist und bleibt
dabei die pandemie bekämpfung ist
gemeinschaftsaufgabe noch sind millionen
erwachsene nicht geimpft impfung
bedeutet zugleich selbstschutz
und schutz von mitmenschen wir haben es
alle zusammen in der hand dies also ist
mein letzter appell als scheidender
bundesminister für gesundheit
helfen sie alle mit dass die korona
politik gelingt dass die korona politik
auch meines nachfolgers von herrn
minister lauterbach gelingt denn es geht
hier nicht um politische karrieren es
steht so viel mehr auf dem spiel für
unser land für die bürgerinnen und
bürger und für deren gesundheit
in diesem sinne wünsche ich ihnen die
minister lauterbach und ihrem team viel
kraft erfolg ausdauer und ich gratuliere
ihnen herzlich in allen wünsche ich
alles alles gute gesundheit und gottes
segen
ja diese dauert das waren die
abschiedsworte von
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen er
war persönlich sehr ergriffen er sagt es
war die schwerste aufgabe die größte
aufgabe seines lebens ihm versagte auch
an kurzen moment lang die stimme das war
also ein sehr emotionaler augenblick und
jetzt hören wir den neuen
bundesgesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren eben wurde wir
entspannt als minister sparen
angesprochen da hatte ich die hoffnung
er würde weitermachen denn zwei minister
kann das haus eigentlich gut brauchen
aber
trotzdem möchte ich hier also das
nächste mal damit beginnen dass ich ganz
was ich einfach ganz herzlich danke sage
wir haben immer gut zusammengearbeitet
es war immer fair
es war immer inhalts getrieben es war
nicht nur in der pandemie so über die
vielen jahre über die wir uns jetzt
schon kennen war es eigentlich immer
unser stil und dafür möchte ich einfach
schlicht ergreifend hier vor allen danke
sagen vielen dank herr sparen
ganz kurz so mir selbst ein paar worte
zur einschätzung ich bin von der
herkunft und auch von der art und weise
die dinge anzugehen sehr stark also
wissenschaftlich geprägt ich bin selbst
arzt und
gesundheitswissenschaftler ich leite das
institut für gesundheitsökonomie und
klinische epidemiologie der uniklinik in
köln bin dort also bei urlaub und
komme aber aus diesem aus dieser
perspektive an die aufgabe heran das ist
wichtig weil also die gesundheitspolitik
aus meiner sicht kann nur dann
erfolgreich sein wenn sie sich in der
wissenschaft verankert findet in der
evidenzbasierten medizin das wird sehr
stark die art und weise bestimmen wie
ich an diese probleme die vor uns liegen
herangehen ich mich auch gleich sagen
was also aus meiner sicht für das haus
die wichtigste aufgabe ist die
wichtigste aufgabe für das haus ist die
pannen wie für deutschland zu beenden
und der nussknacker den wir dafür
verwenden werden den habe ich heute
mitgebracht der ist quasi schon vor
ihnen der nussknacker ist das haus
selbst wenn es mit dem haus schaffen
diese pandemie zu ende zu bringen in den
nächsten monaten alles daran setzen mit
der neuen variante mit der nikon
variante fertig zu werden wir werden die
booster impfungen so schnell wie wir
können weiter in die fläche bringen wir
werden genau dort ansetzen wo
ex minister spanisch grad beschrieben
hat die 30 millionen impfungen bis zum
jahresende die werden wir verfolgen
werden impfstoff beschaffen um diese
erfolgreiche booster impfung kampagne in
die nächsten monate hineinzubringen und
wir werden dann in den monaten danach
mit neuen impfstoffen die auf die
omikron variante angepassten dieses werk
weiterführen denn solange postern und
impfen bis wir die pandemie zu ende
gebracht haben das ist aus meiner sicht
die vordringlichste aufgabe die wir
haben die wir gemeinsam haben und ich
glaube dass wir das gemeinsam schaffen
wir
die
arbeit die geleistet worden ist ist eine
großartige arbeit war dass deutschland
ist durch die ersten drei wellen der
pandemie besser durchgekommen als fast
alle anderen europäischen länder wir
haben eine über sterblichkeit von
ungefähr 4 prozent die vergleichbaren
länder von der altersstruktur
vergleichbaren länder haben eine über
sterblichkeit von acht bis elf prozent
das ist auch der arbeit dieses hauses
und dass es auch ihre arbeit zu
verdanken dafür möchte ich mich ganz
herzlich bedanken und diese arbeit
möchten wir fortsetzen so dass wir
weiterhin auch im vergleich zu anderen
ländern besonders gut durch die panne
gekommen wir haben im gesundheitssystem
zahlreiche aufgaben vor uns design mal
an gearbeitet sind aber die weiter
geführt werden müssen wir müssen die
pflege besser bezahlen wir müssen die
pflege besser ausstatten wir müssen zu
besseren pflege
personalschlüssel können wir müssen zu
den personalschlüssel kommen in einer
art und weise dass sie nicht durch das
bestehende system der fallpauschalen
wieder eingesammelt werden wir müssen in
der
pflegeversorgung der pflegeversicherung
müssen dazu eine situation kommen dass
der eigenanteil die familien nicht
bedrängt und in armut zwingt wir müssen
pflegebedarfs autoschlüssel auch in der
altenpflege umsetzen wir müssen in der
altenpflege dazu kommen dass die
pflegeleistung eine qualität hat dass
sie über das was wir bisher erreicht
haben hinausgehen müssen also in der
intensivmedizin die
versorgung so verbessern dass die
intensiv medizin nicht aus in einer
situation kommt dass sich in der kurve
versorgung auf der einen seite und der
versorgung von patienten mit anderen
erkrankungen einer abwägung getroffen
werden muss wir werden also in der
arzneimittelversorgung anreize schaffen
müssen dass die arzneimittelversorgung
dazu führt dass die forschung in
deutschland intensiviert wird besser
wird wir müssen also in der versorgung
der hausärzte dazu kommen dass wir das
also vor uns liegende mangel system ein
hausärztlicher versorgung abfangen wo
wir es noch können wir brauchen dort
nicht mehr medizinstudierende und müssen
diese medizinstudierenden auch so
ausbilden dass sie in der versorgung
bleiben wollen und nicht in andere
bereiche abwandern wir haben also ein
portfolio von aufgaben vor uns die also
dringlichste aufgabe die bekämpfung der
pandemie aber auch das gesundheitssystem
so aufzuwerten dass es tatsächlich
zukunftssicher ist und auch menschen in
das system bringt denn wir werden
zunehmend probleme haben junge leute für
das für die gesundheitsversorgung zu
finden und auch in die
gesundheitsversorgung zu binden daher
bin ich froh dass wir hier als team
arbeiten werden ich lege allergrößten
wert auf teamarbeit ich werde sehr eng
auch also beispielsweise mit
den personalrat ich werde sehr eng auch
mit der mitarbeitervertretungen arbeiten
ich werde sehr darauf aber darauf achten
dass wir genug personal vor ort haben
und ich bin dankbar dass wir einen teil
unseres teams heute schon vorstellen
können die beiden parlamentarischen
staatssekretäre
sabine dittmer und es kaffanke sind
schon da und konnte neben bereits
vereidigt werden ich bin stolz und froh
dass wir frau doktor an krebs als
staatssekretärin gewinnen konnten die
unser team verstärkt ich bin sehr
dankbar dass staatssekretär steffen hier
weiterarbeiten wird den ich darum
gebeten habe und dem ich dafür danken
durch da auch im namen von bundeskanzler
oder chance den informiert habe dass sie
die bereitschaft haben hier weiter für
uns zu arbeiten
wir werden auch weitere
personalentscheidungen in den nächsten
tagen treffen ich glaube auch dass wir
möglicherweise die leitungsebene des
hauses wieder in dieses zentrale haus
zurückführen so dass wir die nähe also
zum gesamten team haben aber ich glaube
dass wir sind also aufgebaut sind
aufgestellt sind für die aufgaben die
vor uns liegen und wie gesagt die aus
der bekämpfung der pandemie in den
nächsten monaten ist unsere zentrale
aufgabe
wir werden das schaffen
auch wir werden möglicherweise den einen
oder anderen fehler machen aber wir
werden nach vorne gehen und ich möchte
in diesem sinne noch einmal ganz
herzlich jens spahn für die geleistete
arbeit danken und möchte mich auch dafür
bedanken dass er sich bereit erklärt hat
bei dem einen oder anderen punkt noch
mit rat und tat zur seite zu stehen so
haben wir ja immer zusammengearbeitet
und also das freut mich auch dass wir
beide dann doch noch einmal gemischte
minister geworden sind nachdem wir es
dem anderen jeweils gegönnt hätten aber
selbst davon ausgegangen sind dass wir
es werden und beides ist nicht eine
fällung nicht in erfüllung gegangen
somit also vielen dank an alle die heute
hier sind vielen dank an den nussknacker
für die großen aufgaben die vor uns
liegen und glückauf wir werden es
gemeinsam schaffen vielen dank
ja so warnt die amtsübergabe im
bundesgesundheitsministerium meine damen
und herren vielleicht gucken wir noch
mal ganz kurz zu meinem kollegen gar zu
achten von valora oder wir bleiben drauf
ich guck mal an die regie
ja wir gehen jetzt weiter zurück joachim
von fallois wir haben ja die beiden
statements der minister sparen und und
lauterbach gehört ja glatt joachim also
es war dann doch sehr emotional bei
ihren sparen als er den pflegekräften
gedankt hat und als er noch mal im
angesichts des ernstes der lage corona
pandemie gesagt hat das war die
schwerste aufgabe bisher in seinem leben
kurz die stimme
ja das ist so entspannend 2002 den
deutschen bundestag gekommen seitdem
kenne ich ihn auch und es gilt nicht nur
für ihren sparen sondern für all diese
politiker die wichtigen entscheidungen
treffen müssen die aus dem fernsehen
bekannt sind das sind auch nur menschen
sage ich mal und diese pandemie hat
allen das maximale abverlangt auch das
wissen das sie entspannen schon sehr
frühzeitig geteilt hat das auch fehler
vorkommen werden und dass solche fehler
eventuell dann auch durchaus für den ein
oder anderen betroffenen zur katastrophe
werden kann in den masken fehlen oder
betten um das ist jetzt sparen und
anderen politikern immer wieder bewusst
und ich glaube dass viele in der
bevölkerung einfach zu hart urteilen
über politiker die natürlich auch fehler
machen auch teilweise reihenweise fehler
wo man sich dann fragt warum muss das so
sein
aber ich fand es sehr aufschlussreich
denn sparen wie gesagt hat ja noch
einmal darauf hingewiesen auf 2013 als
man damals spd und cdu/csu gemeinsam
verhandelt hat er mit karl lauterbach
und dann ist der minister den ich
übrigens vorhin vergessen habe der nicht
in die wirtschaft gegangen ist nämlich
hermann gröhe zunächst
gesundheitsminister geworden zur
verwunderung der beiden anderen und in
der tat es ist tatsächlich jetzt so dass
beide dann doch noch gesundheitsminister
waren oder jetzt geworden sind also so
schließt sich der kreis und vielleicht
kann man auch noch sagen dass der
jetzige minister etwas zu spät dran war
liegt auch an einer besonderheit die in
diesen minuten überall in den
ministerien stattfindet er hat nämlich
schon seine beiden
staatssekretäre vereidigt sabine dittmer
und edgar franke das sind zwei
bundestagsabgeordnete das sind die
parlamentarischen staatssekretäre und
dann ist immer von weiteren
staatssekretären die rede das sind sehr
wichtige leute sind die beamteten
staatssekretäre zunächst der steffen der
in diesem ministerium zunächst erhalten
bleibt von jens spahn ein mann und dann
antje draheim die auch eine ganz
interessante historie hat die war
nämlich lange jahre hier bevor mich
diese des landes mecklenburg vorpommern
und ist gerade erst vor einem monat
befördert worden als staatssekretärin
beim gesundheitsminister in mecklenburg
vorpommern da ist sie nicht lange
geblieben sondern ist gebeten worden
jetzt hier nach berlin zu wechseln also
so schnell kann es manchmal gehen ja das
ist ja das interessante an diesem
nachmittag bei den einzelnen
amtsübergabe dass er auch die
menschliche komponente wie wir es gerade
gesehen haben nicht zu kurz kommt herr
professor meyer politologe von der uni
in bonn wir haben auch karl lauterbach
reden hören er hat sehr viele
vorschusslorbeeren gekriegt nun muss er
zeigen was er wirklich auf dem kasten
hat und ist ja im prinzip schon das war
wie würden sie das dann beurteilen war
das schon seine erste rede als neuer
gesundheitsminister
jedenfalls die programmatik hat er ja
geäußert hatte verschiedene punkte
angegeben
pflegeintensiv medizin und so weiter
insofern in der tat war es ein portfolio
präsent und trägt er zum fortschritt der
gesamten
des kabinetts mit seiner programmatik
bei und wo wir vorher zweifel hatten ob
er so von seiner art auch ein
ministerium bleiben könnte hat er
innerhalb kürzester zeit eigentlich hier
uns beliefert mit mit einer der sache
die ihn umtreibt und er war
offensichtlich ja schon im ministerium
entsprechende aktiv mit der verwaltung
usw
insofern großen großer eindruck den ihr
hier gemacht hat und wir könnten da
glaube ich sehr zufrieden sein mit mit
seiner wahl mit seinem anfang vielen
dank herr professor man ja so liebe
zuschauer wir haben ja schon den ganzen
nachmittag die amtsübergabe hier
übertragen wir hatten vor kurzem ein
kleines technisches problem die
amtsübergabe von peter altmaier an
robert habeck im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium obertal
bild neuer vizekanzler nicht nur
wirtschaftsminister ist auch für den
klimaschutz verantwortlich und seine
rede die wollen wir ihnen natürlich
unbedingt noch zeigen und ich würde
einfach dieser sie bitten diese
abzuspielen
ich will für mich sagen dass
parteizugehörigkeit und mitgliedschaft
an sich erst einmal etwas gutes ist bei
aller politischen debatte die parteien
miteinander haben es zeugt davon dass
menschen bereit sind für ihre kommune
für ihre für irland für ihre stadt
verantwortung zu übernehmen für ihre
überzeugung und ihre ideen namen zeit
energie herzugeben insofern spielt
parteimitgliedschaft für mich überhaupt
gar keine rolle auf gar keinen fall eine
negative rolle ich würde gerne hoffen
dass sie ihre erkenntnisse ihre
voreinstellungen ihre wärter norm sogar
nutzen in diesen gesprächen die wir
führen werden ihre meinung nicht hinter
dem berg zu halten widersprechen sie mir
sagen sie mir was sie denken suchen sie
den diskurs so wie ich ihnen
widersprechen werde und ihnen irgendwann
mit meinen fragen auf die nerven gehen
werde und dann soll das bessere argument
gewinnen nur geschlagen von dem noch
besseren
so würde ich es gerne hand haben und du
würde ich kollegialität gerne leben wenn
es gelingt dann ist kollegialität der
sammelbegriff für loyalität für
integrität und für das einstehen
füreinander
umgekehrt so offen wir miteinander
diskutieren wollen und den besten weg
suchen
würde ich darum bitten dass nach außen
wir geschlossen agieren dass das was
politik und auch ein ministerium
manchmal so unattraktiv macht das
schlecht übereinander reden das
durchstechen nicht passiert die
offenheit nach innen und die loyalität
nach außen und das soll das
markenzeichen der nächsten vier jahre
werden und ich werde versuchen mein
beitrag dafür zu leisten so gut ich es
eben kann
ich weiß liebe verrat dass ich als
grüner minister und halte heute nochmal
mahnende worte auf den weg gegeben
besonders hohe erwartungen zu erfüllen
habe was gleichstellung angeht und ich
will mich dieser verantwortung stellen
ich will die sieben prozent mindestens
schaffen der anteil von frauen in
führungspositionen
soll weiter gesteigert werden und ich
weiß dass das nicht nur worte sein
können sondern die den auch taten folgen
müssen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
ein bisschen ich habe es angesprochen
und die kolleginnen die jetzt zu ihnen
kommen werden stehen schon ein bisschen
dafür werde ich versuchen die
leitungsebene umzustrukturieren ich
bringe ein bisschen die erfahrung mit
die ich in schleswig holstein als ich
sechs jahre lang dort minister war
gesammelt habe
neben den staatssekretären und
staatssekretären die hier sitzen ich
weiß gar nicht das können sie jetzt
vielleicht nicht sehen aber ich kann sie
sehen die parlamentarische
staatssekretärin franziska brantner
michael kellner und oliver krischer
sitzen hier irgendwo wenn von da aus
einem kamerateam würden die sehen sonst
finden die die bestimmt auf
irgendwelchen homepages wald und die
kommenden verbeamteten staatssekretäre
anja hajduk für den bereich z und die
wird anja hajduk wird auch gleichzeitig
die schnittstelle für die grüne
regierungsarbeit gegenüber dem
kanzleramt darstellen foto filipp für
die bereiche außenwirtschaft industrie
und digitalisierung sven giegold für die
bereiche europa
mittelstand und wirtschaftspolitik und
patrick reichen für die energie und
klimaschutz bereiche sie werden das
genau so leben wie ich es eben gerade
skizziert habe wir werden darüber hinaus
die
kommunikationsabteilung aus der linie
aus der abteilung rausholen und sie wird
von nicola kabel als
stabsstelle geleitet werden gleichzeitig
als sprecherin des ministers und robert
heyne ich jetzt hier der auch die
koordinierungs referate aus der linie
rausholen wird so dass wir dann eine art
ansprechstelle schnittstelle für das
ganze haus sind und so ist es gedacht
dass wir aus der leitungsebene
durchlässig mit dem haus kommunizieren
und einen aber kite dann auch in der
formalen struktur schaffen ich freue
mich dass das ministerbüro in den ich
nehme an für sie die bewährten händen
von noah habib sadek weiter geleitet
wird und ich auf dem team aufbauen kann
dass peter altmaier um sich gesammelt
hat so dass sie auch sehen dass hier
keine bilderstürmer kommen sondern dass
wir mit den erfahrungen die wir
mitbringen mit den politischen
programmen die wir mitbringen auf der
substanz auf der auf dem
kenntnisreichtum auf der erfahrung des
hauses aufbauen wollen wir werden
sicherlich weitere schritte gehen aber
es sind sollen lernen der schritte seien
die abteilung el sol meiner vorstellung
nach zu einer transformation politik
abteilung weiterentwickelt werden ein
paar stellen die ich als vizekanzler mit
in dieses haus bringen sollen nicht nur
alleine der leitungsebene zur verfügung
gestellt werden sondern dem haus als
ganzes so dass diese abteilung
transformations- politik dann ein
bindeglied sein kann zwischen den
klassischen energie und klimaschutz
abteilung und den klassischen
wirtschafts und industriepolitischen
abteilungen aber gleichzeitig auch eine
art übersetzungs abteilung in die
gesellschaftliche wirklichkeit sein soll
oder zumindestens werden kann denn wir
wissen ja dass die transformation
natürlich erst mal als politisches
projekt gut zu beschreiben was ich dir
gleich noch mal ein bisschen darauf ein
aber in der gesellschaftlichen realität
natürlich ganz andere fragen aufwirft
das was an gesetzesentwürfen oder ein
förderprogramm gut aussieht kann in
bestimmten regionen branchen im
ländlichen raum zu elementaren
verwerfungen führen kann soziale fragen
nach sich ziehen die mit zu bearbeiten
erscheint mir grundbedingungen des
erfolges zu sein für das was wir
gemeinsam in den nächsten vier jahren
und vielleicht ein bisschen darüber
hinaus hinbekommen können ich weiß nicht
wer von ihnen skat spielt aber beim skat
gibt es zwei typen von skat spielerin
oder skatspieler die einen können immer
nur kranken von oben herab sagt die
buchen dann die esse und die anderen
gehen über die dörfer buchstäblich
sammeln erst die karten ein und dann am
ende holt man den erfolgreichen ich
glaube dass die große transformation für
die wir stehen ein über die dörfer gehen
bedeutet und zwar im buchstäblichen
sinne mit den menschen reden mit den
sozialpartnern mit den verbänden mit den
umweltverbänden in das gespräch kommen
und diese politische kultur auch zu
leben dahin müssen wir kommen und das
was ich mitbringen kann ist vielleicht
diesen weg ein stück weit mit zu ebnen
und das ist der vorsatz der sich dann
auch über die umgruppierung hoffentlich
materialisiert und erweisen wird
sehr geehrte damen und herren die
transformation der größten
industrienationen europas der
viertgrößten volkswirtschaft der welt
richtung klimaneutralität ist bei all
den krisen die wir gegenwärtig zu
bestehen haben die wir sehen und die
deutsche wirtschaft so hart getroffen
hat und ich kann nur noch einmal danke
sagen wie schnell dann auch dieses haus
die wirtschaftsprogramme die
unterstützungsprogramme die
überbrückungshilfen aufgestellt haben
das hat halt viele betriebe und betriebe
ist schon wieder so ein politischer
begriff vielen menschen den ruinen
erspart hat arbeitslosigkeit verhindert
hat dafür gesorgt dass die
wirtschaftspolitische substanz in
deutschland erhalten geblieben ist
darüber hinaus allerdings ist die
transformation der großen industriellen
kraft deutschlands richtung
klimaneutralität sicherlich
die große strukturelle aufgabe unserer
zeit die große strukturelle aufgabe
dieser regierung und dieser legislatur
aber darüber hinaus dieses jahrzehnts
und wo findet die stadt wo bündeln sich
die energien wo bündeln sich aber auch
oder wo treffen auch die widersprüche
aufeinander hier in diesem ministerium
in diesem haus das wird debatte nach
sich ziehen es ist aber auch eine
wahnsinnige chance
aufsetzend auf der ehrwürdigen tradition
dieses hauses hier wo die soziale
marktwirtschaft in deutschland
durchgesetzt wurde und damit der
wohlstand dieser republik erfunden und
geschaffen wurde diese
ordnungspolitischen leitplanken
weiterzuentwickeln und aus der sozialen
eine ökologisch soziale marktwirtschaft
zu schaffen das wird die große aufgabe
unserer zeit sein
das ist eine doppelte verantwortung die
damit einher geht erstens das projekt zu
bestehen und zweitens die ökonomischen
prozesse so zu denken dass nur das
rechnen der summen am ende nicht den
erfolg bringen wird wenn man verluste
und gewinne zusammenzieht und die zahl
im schwarzen landet drängen galt das
ökonomisch häufig als erfolgreiche
wirtschaftspolitik
wir wissen aber heute aus der ökonomie
aus der wirtschaftswissenschaft aber wir
wissen ist eigentlich aus dem privaten
selbst dass menschen teilhaben wollen am
erfolg erfolgreich sein wollen und dass
dieses erfolg haben wollen die bedingung
dafür ist dass ökonomische
transformation insgesamt nur gelingen
kann wir haben dafür in dem
koalitionsvertrag
ein paar vorkehrungen getroffen das
zusammenlegen von klimaschutz energie
und wirtschafts mittelstandspolitik ist
eine davon die andere ist dass die
investition in deutschland auch durch
öffentliche investitionen noch einmal
gehebelt werden sollen wir werden in den
nächsten jahren ein großes
investitionsvolumen an öffentlichem und
privatem geld stemmen müssen ja los
treten müssen politisch haben wir dafür
einen klima und transformations- form
geschaffen der mit vielen milliarden
aufgeladen ist und dann die möglichkeit
zur verfügung stellt dass das was
politik was der staat leisten sollte
nämlich infrastrukturelle
voraussetzungen zu schaffen für
transformation auch gewährleistet werden
kann wir werden es also strukturieren
müssen hier in diesem haus wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass das geld ein hebel hat
das tatsächlich dann die ökonomischen
prozesse in den gang kommen dazu die
große transformation des industriellen
oder des energiepolitischen sektors der
ausstieg noch einmal beschleunigt aus
der kohle der ausbau von erneuerbaren
energien dann die verkoppelung der
stromproduktion der erneuerbaren strom
produktion mit den anderen sektoren mit
der industrie das wird im kern die
arbeit der nächsten vier jahre seien
neben all den konkreten einzelnen fragen
krisen und programmen die gemeldet
worden ich habe in die bücher
reingeschaut ich weiß wie breit die
aufgabe des hauses ist aber gemessen
wird am ende die große historische
aufgabe an dem gelingen dieses projektes
und die alle anderen projekte die wir
haben werden rein spielen in diese große
transformations- aufgabe wenn ich das
politisch wirtschaftspolitisch umreißen
soll dann würde ich das was wir vorhaben
einen idealistischen pragmatismus nennen
realistisch weil es natürlich eine
zielvorgabe gibt und das darf ich sagen
eine sehr hochgesteckte ziel vorgabe
wird der altmaier hat es eben gerade
gesagt und hat es auf seine besondere
art in einer ehrlichkeit ausgesprochen
die politisch einfach ungewöhnliches
lieber peter altmaier sie sagten wir
waren damals noch nicht so weit die
amtierende bundesregierung war noch
nicht so weit zu sehen wie dringlich die
aufgabe von klimaneutralität ist und
dann mit anlaufschwierigkeiten haben wir
die gesetze dann nachgeschärft nun sind
die gesetze da und sie sind jetzt schon
ohne dass die zahlen nachgeschärft
wurden und sie wissen dass einige
kritiker sagen das leicht alles noch
nicht um auf 1,5 grad zu kommen sie sind
natürlich jetzt schon immens bis 2030 so
sagt es das gesetz das die große
koalition verabschiedet hat müssen die
co2-emission auf 65 - 65 prozent gesenkt
werden und 2040 sagen - 88 prozent das
heißt das ist fast alles das sind 90
prozent um die zehn prozent
machen den kohl am ende nicht gut wenn
wir sie auch haben aber die 90 prozent
die sind entscheidend dafür dass wir die
klimaneutralität erreichen können in
knapp 18 jahren in knapp 20 jahren in 18
jahren die wir zeit haben und das ist
wie sie alle wissen politisch im grunde
morgen deswegen brauchen wir den
idealismus dass es gelingen kann wir
brauchen aber vor allem auch ein
pragmatisches vorgehen nicht ein
dogmatisches vorgehen ich will für mich
und für die kommenden oder jetzt schon
berufen den staatssekretären und
staatssekretäre sagen dass die
ideologische debatte nicht die
handschrift der nächsten vier jahre
werden soll sondern der erfolg der
output das was umsetzung stark als das
soll gemacht werden und die instrumente
müssen so gemixt werden dass wir
möglichst erfolgreich sind an der stelle
deswegen halte ich debatten darüber ob
es mehr oder weniger staat geben soll ob
mehr reguliert oder die reguliert werden
soll eigentlich fehl am platze die sind
natürlich interessant aber am ende ist
das das richtige instrument also
möglichst großem erfolg führt dass das
geld das große geld das bereitgestellt
wird verausgabt wird dass wir schneller
plant schneller bauen dass wir die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit in diesem land noch
einmal erhöhen denn die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit das ist die
tradition dieses hauses und sie ist die
bedingung dafür dass wir erfolgreich
sein können die kreativität der märkte
den mut etwas neues zu wagen das können
belohnt wird das große
industrieunternehmen sich wandeln das
neue unternehmen in konkurrenz durchaus
zu den großen wieder an dem markt
erstehen das hat dieses land stark
gemacht ein hoch kompetitive wettbewerbs
raum den zu schaffen das wird die
deutsche volkswirtschaft das wird die
europäische wirtschaft schaffen stärken
dafür allerdings braucht es natürlich
dann sonst wäre es kein idealistischer
pragmatismus klare zielvorgaben klare
rahmenbedingungen und das wiederum wird
hier geleistet werden müssen das was den
erfolg bringt die große krise unserer
zeit zu bewerkstelligen kleiner zu
machen beziehungsweise zu überwinden das
wird belohnt werden müssen an den
märkten und entsprechend der wandel von
der sozialen zur ökologisch sozialen
marktwirtschaft die externalisierung
kosten nicht als heimlicher gewinner in
den unternehmen zu lassen sondern durch
regeln oder bepreisung dafür zu sorgen
dass sich die ganze kreativität des
marktes dem ziel der klimaneutralität
richtet und sowie prosperität reichtum
wohlstand mit dem schutz der planetaren
grenzen verbinden können wenn wir das
schaffen werden wir gemeinsam geschichte
schreiben dann werden wir geschichte
geschrieben haben und wenn wir dann im
jahr 2040 zurückblicken und tatsächlich
sagen deutschland ist in den jahren des
anlaufs der letzten legislatur und dann
mit dieser legislatur tatsächlich den
großen schritt gegangen hat gezeigt wie
eine große volkswirtschaft gleichzeitig
aus atom und kohlestrom aussteigen kann
und trotzdem die märkte der zukunft
erfolgreich mit bespielen kann wohlstand
und gute arbeit im land gehalten wurden
das erfolgreich zu bestehen das wird
dann tatsächlich ein kleiner schriftzug
in dem geschichtsbuch dieser republik
sein an dem wir dann schreiben können
sehr geehrte damen und herren diese
erneuerung des wettbewerbs gedankens
dieses sich auf einen instrumenten mix
einlassen das wird unsere arbeit kriegen
wir sind darauf angewiesen ich bin
darauf angewiesen dass sie mit ihrer
kenntnis mit ihrem wissen mit ihren
idealismus aber auch mit ihrem
pragmatismus mir helfen uns helfen
diesen weg zu gehen
peter altmaier hat es angesprochen und
wird irgendwann vielleicht wie eine
kleine persönliche legende zwischen uns
sein ein heißer sommertag im jahr 2012
in friedrichskoog
wo wir uns kennenlernten ja war damals
umweltminister brach auf in eine
klimaschutz tour durch deutschland und
da friedrichskoog wurde ich wohne in
flensburg für mich ist das schon fast
süden aber für alle menschen südlich der
elbe gehört das zum echten norden im
norden liegt begann seiner reise dort
und wir diskutierten dort was
energiepolitisch notwendig ist welche
chancen damals mein bundesland aber auch
deutschland hat aber welche
herausforderungen dann dort auch
passierten war vor uns lagen jetzt herr
altmaier zehn jahre später scheiden sie
aus einem amt aus von gewalt hat es
gesagt nach 27 jahren in der politik
1994 als bundesminister gewählt dann in
drei ministerien politische
verantwortung übertragen und das
mittlere ministerium war das kanzleramt
in einer zeit wo deutschland die 2015 16
jahre politisch bestehen musste in einer
politischen aufheizung wie seit der
deutschen wiedervereinigung
wahrscheinlich noch nicht gewesen und
hoffentlich angesichts der korona
pandemie nicht wieder passieren werden
sie haben die verantwortung getragen und
das darf ich als politiker einer partei
sagen die damals in der opposition sind
sie haben sie keine news gemeistert in
einer zeit wo die politische nervosität
so groß waren dass teilweise kompass und
ordnung verloren gegangen sind das wo
wertevorstellungen und vielleicht auch
das normative korsett dieser republik
unter dem populismus drohten über gewalt
zu werden haben sie auch sie als
personen zusammen mit der
bundeskanzlerin kurs und richtung
gehalten sie haben also diesem land viel
gegeben sie haben deutschland gedient
wie ist die bundeskanzlerin mal gesagt
hat und scheiden jetzt aus diesem amt
aus
vielleicht
nachdenklich wie ich sie kennengelernt
habe und was sie als mensch besonders
macht und auch zu einem besonderen
politiker gemacht hat vielleicht auch
ein bisschen ermüdet und erschöpft nach
all den jahren würde es verdenken aber
hoffentlich auch mit einer perspektive
dass die zeit die vor ihm liegt eine
gute wird sie haben mir ein buch
überreicht dass ich in meinen
schlaflosen nächten vielleicht wieder
zum schlafen de ich habe ihn auch ein
buch mitgebracht ich habe ich jetzt auf
englisch genommen das heißt 1900 oder
1493 auf deutsch 1493 die welt die
columbus kreierte oder schuf mit dem
besonderer hintergedanken erstens ist es
eines der besten bücher dass ich in den
letzten jahren gelesen habe und zweitens
handelt es eben von der welt die
columbus nicht entdeckte sondern schuf
die entdeckung von amerika war keine
entdeckung von amerika sondern sie war
der beginn der globalisierung und sie
war eine veränderte welt die danach
entstanden ist jeder schritt den wir tun
und ihnen auch sie jetzt in den nächsten
lebensabschnitt tun werden wird zu einer
veränderung führen insofern ein
spannendes buch in der sache aber eben
auch ein gedanke oder ein festhalten
dessen was jedes tun dass wir
bewerkstelligen auslöst mit der welt und
dann habe ich ihn mitgebracht ich weiß
gar nicht ist wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen albern aber vielleicht passt es
zu ihrer freiheit ich weiß gar nicht ob
sie so etwas tragen würden aber als wir
uns in friedrichskoog trafen schloss
sich an die politische diskussion über
energie und
klimapolitik eine kleine wanderung an
und wenn man dort oben an der küste lebt
und ein bisschen im wald unterwegs ist
gibt es also ein großes ökologisches
problem neben der klimaveränderung das
sind die ganzen plastikmüll einträge die
es dort gibt und es gibt es eine kleine
initiative die aus den fischernetzen und
man denkt fischernetze was soll mir das
denn es ist wirklich so dass die schnüre
der fischernetze zu einem massiven
problem im meer und im naturschutz
geworden sind kleine armbänder machen
und es ist mich in hippie das gebe ich
zu aber ich bin minister aus einer
hippie partei und vielleicht gehört zu
der neu gewonnenen freiheit dazu dass
sie auf solche armbänder aus schnüren
aus alten fischernetzen tragen
jedenfalls hat einen guten zweck gedient
und deswegen die peter altmaier mit
aller kraft und allen guten wünschen und
aller dankbarkeit für all das was ich
für deutschland geleistet haben viel
kraft viel zeit alle guten ideen und
alles gute für den nächsten
lebensabschnitt danke dass sie diese
übergabe so fair gestaltet haben danke
dass sie mir und uns dieses haus
übergeben wir werden uns nach kräften
bemühen gut aufzupassen und ich hoffe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dass sie
mir helfen dieses haus weiter gut zu
gestalten und aus diesem haus haus das
beste für deutschland leisten zu können
vielen dank
[Applaus]
ja liebe zuschauer das ist ein
nachmittag der amtsübergabe die minister
die scheidenden bundesminister übergeben
ihre häuser an die nachfolge zuletzt
haben wir noch gesehen peter altmaier
und das war die rede von robert habeck
dem neuen minister für wirtschaft und
klima er hat seinem nachfolger ein
armband geschenk wie wir gelernt haben
wir sind heute bei phoenix schon seit
acht uhr dreißig hier am start wir haben
diesen tag der neuen bundesregierung
denen am zu übergaben verfolgt aus
berlin live und mich würde jetzt mal
interessieren mein kollege gerd joachim
von fallois hat
unzählige interviews geführt heute würde
ich mal sagen der tu aachen was ist denn
das fazit ein ganz persönliches an
diesem tag wenn du den revue passieren
lässt was wird ja immer im gedächtnis
bleiben
vielleicht sogar der letzte auftritt
robert habeck in einer krawatte habe ich
auch noch nicht erlebt und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass peter altmaier so
ein armband nicht tragen wird ob robert
habeck auch weiter krawatte trägt als
minister das werden wir genau beobachten
und interessant ist ja auch wenn man ihm
gelauscht hat und das ist vielleicht
auch ein fingerzeig für das was die
ampel will dieses wirtschaftsministerium
heißt eigentlich wirtschaft und klima
eigentlich hat man zwischendurch das
gefühl dort redet ein klima minister
also ein umweltminister aber dieses soll
sich ja durch all diese ministerien
ziehen die die ampel jetzt seit heute
bekleidet und ich finde gerade diese
übergabe im wirtschafts- und
klimaministerium hat das für den
heutigen tag noch einmal sehr deutlich
gemacht vielen dank herr professor
tilman mayer von der uni in bonn wie
fällt das fazit des politologen aus
würden sie sagen wir stehen am anfang
einer neuen zeit
also diese klima aktien schätzung ist
natürlich ganz deutlich auch wenn man
gegessen mitbekommen hat was man gehört
hat auch koalitionsvertrag dann ist das
thema klima universell liegt über allem
sozusagen
auch bei frau bär frau
ein cooles bkm bereich
bisher den kulturen der grüne minister
dieser woche wo claudia roth auch gesagt
hat kulturstaatsministerin das auch bei
ihr klima ist überall
grün geführten ministerien sonst spricht
überall sozusagen bot man will oder
nicht natürlich war da sind die
übergänge hier harmonisch eigentlich
angelegt das was eigentlich mit der
politik nichts zu tun hat aber man hat
den eindruck auf bei der übergabe im
moment aber auch davor beim contest und
heitz ministerium das ist ein sehr sehr
harmonisches gefühl zwischen den beiden
man könnte auch oppositionelle oder
bisschen unleidlich seien nichts
dergleichen sondern es würde ja ein
konsens ausgedrückt das ist relativ
ungewöhnlich wenn ich sie gleich mal
unterbrechen darf an der stelle was
denken sie es hat sich ein bisschen
transportiert bei den einzelnen reden
woran liegt das also ich hatte zum
beispiel sehr stark das gefühl dass das
gerade bei der amtsübergabe von jens
spahn an karl lauterbach bei beiden rede
beitreten zum ausdruck kamen wie groß
die achtung des jeweils einen vor der
leistung des anderen ist weil das in der
ganz scharfen krise eine denkbar große
herausforderung ist yaman man kennt sich
man schätzt sich was eben der zuhörer
zuschauer aus der ferne so gar nicht
wahrnimmt wie wie eng dann doch in der
berliner
kultur die beziehungen sind oder
gewachsen sind insofern ist es macht es
eigentlich für die politische kultur der
bundesrepublik durchaus einen guten
eindruck man muss sich natürlich
hinterher auch auseinandersetzen können
das tut man ja dann auch später die die
probleme kommen aber zunächst einmal
glaube ich ist ein ganz gutes zeichen
für unsere demokratie
es darf natürlich nicht zu viel konsens
geben das wäre auch schlecht aber den
eindruck konnte man eigentlich nicht
unbedingt haben und inhaltlich hier
etwas vorgetragen wurde ist sowie
ähnlich wie bei
lauterbach nur viel länger wie gerade
eben dass eben diese ökosoziale
marktwirtschaft und die ganze
klimapolitische akzentsetzung oder
transformationen der begriff kam jahr
unzählig viele male vor
da wird also dieses
wirtschaftsministerium ordentlich
umgebaut hat ihren eindruck ich denke
mal wahrscheinlich ist die versuchung
nicht so groß dass da zu viel harmonie
bleibt vielleicht die letzte frage jetzt
nach berlin ein gerd joachim von fallois
man muss tatsächlich dazu sagen das ist
das erste mal dass eine ampel in
deutschland regiert es gibt ja dadurch
ziemlich große gegensätze auch wenn wir
das in den letzten wochen und monaten
überhaupt nicht öffentlich zu spüren
bekommen haben aber wie groß sind denn
die unterschiede zwischen den einzelnen
koalitionären und was denken sie denn
was könnten die ersten knapp punkte sein
an denen man sich reiben wird
nun die bewährungsprobe für die ampel
beginnt mit dem heutigen tag man hat
sich erstaunlich gut zusammengerauft es
ist bewundernswert
dass 300 politiker einen
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben haben und
es ist nichts raus gesichert es ist ein
großer vertrauensvorschuss da das merkt
man auch wenn man mit den politikern im
gespräch ist das imponiert auch der
gegenseite bei der cdu csu wie ich weiß
und das ist der gemeinsame geist es
manchmal ein bisschen überhöht worden
man muss jetzt mal abwarten was die
ampel in der täglichen arbeit zu leisten
imstande ist aber auf jeden fall wenn
man diesen geist weiter mit sich führen
kann dass man gemeinsam an dingen
arbeitet vielleicht auch eben über
ministerien grenzen hinweg nicht jeder
nur sein ding macht sondern man eben
wirklich gemeinsam die zukunft
deutschlands gestalten will dann hat die
ampel eine sehr gute zeit vor sich ich
bedanke mich für diesen doch recht
munteren nachmittag bei ihnen nach
berlin fährt joachim von fall war
professor meyer hier in unser bonner
studio ihrer liebe zuschauer und der tag
der ist noch lange nicht zu ende wir
erwarten natürlich noch auf die
statements der amtsübergabe der neuen
bundes aussenministerin aus dem
auswärtigen amt annalena baerbock zum
ersten mal hat eine frau dieses amt inne
und zum beispiel auch der neue
landwirtschaftsminister cem özdemir
meine kollegen in der redaktion sind
gerade noch dabei das alles für sie auch
zu bearbeiten zusammenzuschneiden und um
17 uhr 30 kann ich ihnen nur empfehlen
übernimmt hier mein kollege hans werner
fittkau mit phoenix der tat und da
kriegen sie dann alles noch mal in einer
komprimierten
zusammenfassung dass der tag der des
amtswechsels jahr fielen amtswechsel in
berlin wir haben eine neue
bundesregierung und wir haben natürlich
einen neuen bundeskanzler der neunte in
der bundesrepublik deutschland olaf
scholz ist heute gewählt worden der
vierte sozialdemokrat der ins
bundeskanzleramt einziehen wird und
seinen weg dahin den schauen wir uns
jetzt nochmal
[Musik]